わかった、やあ、
みなさん、お立ち寄りいただきありがとうございます
この
機会に生配信をするのは久しぶりですが、
日本語の発音や音程に関する動画を作るのも久しぶりです
そこで、今日は少し時間をとって、
本当に役立つ
日本語の発音とピッチアクセントの
ヒントを詳しく説明したいと思います。
事前にいくつかのグラフィックを準備して、グラフィックが
なかったらもっと有益になるようにしました。
皆さんのコメントが
ここの
2 番目の画面に表示されているので、
途中でいくつかの質問に答えようと思います
が、
このプレゼンテーションには多くの情報が含まれているので、
簡単に説明したいと思います。
質問が本当に山積し始めたら、
私が質問を選ぶのは難しいでしょう。
だから
本当に質問に答えてもらいたいのなら、
スーパーチャットのようにしてください。
1 ドルなどはわかりません。そう
すれば選択しやすくなります。それでは、
始めましょう。
今日のこのプレゼンテーションで最初にやりたいことは、
ちょっとした情報やヒントを提供したいということです。 日本語のアルファベットのすべての音について、
また、知っておくべきピッチ事故のルールを詳しく解説します。それでは、
母音から始めましょう。
これらの母音が画面に表示されることを願っています。
えー、今、私が日本語の発音とピッチアクセントシリーズで普段やっていることを見てみましょう。
右下隅にリンクされている patreon には、すべてのサウンドを詳細に
分類したこのようなグラフィックがたくさんあります。
今日はこれらのグラフィックのいくつかを使用しますが、
情報量には制限がありました このプレゼンテーションのため
に具体的にどれだけのグラフィックスを準備できるかは考えられます
が、プレゼンテーション全体を通してこのようなグラフィックスがいくつか表示されます。
まあ、ハイテクですね。でも、母音については、
個々のグラフィックスの母音を代わりに行うつもりです。 または、
個々の母音のグラフィックを作成するのではなく、むしろ集中することに集中したいと思います。ちなみに、
これらを
実際に簡単に説明します。これが、「ああ、これは、これは、ああ、
これは、
そして」の舌の配置です。 これは、
それ
自体が完全に役立つわけではありませんが、
私は物事を分解している間、Patreon シリーズでこれらのグラフィックを一度に
数分画面上に表示しているので、
そこにはもっと役立つものがたくさんあります
が、とにかく始めましょう 私が
この特定の
音の列に集中したいのは中母音です。
これは、これら
5 つの音の中で、少しの情報があれば最も多く
の学習者が恩恵を受けると私が考える音だからです。
これが具体的に何を意味するのかを説明します。 それは
英語の母音はuの音です、
あなたの唇はこのように見えます、ああ、
私があなたと言うと私の唇は丸くなり、
また突き出ます、
あなた、しかし
日本語では、
本質的にはあります、
唇が丸まることはありません、
ええと、しかし おそらくそれについて考える最良の方法は、
日本語では唇は
一般的にニュートラルで
、唇の突出も
ないので、それはわかりませんが、
私が言うならそうです、
そして
この特定の音にはいわゆる唇の圧縮が少しあるということです
唇の端が少しだけ盛り上がるみたいな感じだけど、それは
もっと端的な感じです
考えてみてください 一番良い方法は、
唇を丸めないで、
唇を前に突き出すつもりはない
ので、英語で「you」と言う
と、それに相当する「you」を
日本語で言うと、私の唇の違いを見てください、あなた、
それは英語で、それから
日本語で言うとそれはあなたです あなたは、
多くの日本人が
英語を母国語とする人が、例えば「あゆみ」という
日本語名を言うときに犯す間違いです。
ここではたくさんのことが起こっていますが、
彼らが犯す間違いの1つは、英語の「U」を英語で言うことです。
真ん中は
英語のyouと同じで、
結局彼らはああ、あなたはユミだと言うことになります
が、またそれは
アユミではありません、アユミ、
アユミ、
アユミです、
私の英語の発音では
ピッチアクセントも間違っていて、
たくさんのことが起こっていますが、
最高の
方法です あなたについて、あなた、ええ、それは
同じです、ええと、あなたはそう
でしょう、あなたはあなたとは言わないでしょう、あなたはあなただと
言うでしょう、そしてまた
少し唇の圧縮があるので、あなたの唇は
あなたの唇の端が少し入るかもしれませんが、
あなたはただ
日本語の「えー」の音では、唇が突き出るのを避けたいし、唇が丸まることも避けたいです。4
番目の母音があるので、これも
少し難しいですが、
情報が多すぎるので、
今日のプレゼンテーションで取り上げたいと思います。
えーと、飛ばします。
興味のある人は
私の母音のレッスンをチェックしてみてください。
私の
ピッチアクセントシリーズの母音についてのレッスンがいくつかあるので、
今からこの音の列に進みましょう。
最初に
取り上げたいのは、ピッチアクセントや発音を勉強したことがない人は、「k」の音を発する
ときの舌の位置がどこにあるか知っていますかということです。
カオス、お立ち寄りいただきありがとうございます。
言語学
音声学音韻論を勉強したことがない場合、K の音を発声するときに
舌がどこにあるのかを概念化するのは難しいです
が、
実際にはこの位置にあるので、
舌の後ろの部分のようなものが来ます。 それで、「
k」という音を出してみると、
舌が口の後ろ上部に触れるのと同じように感じられるはずです。そして
何が
起こるかというと、舌がそこに触れます。
あなたがその音を言うとき、あなたの
舌は解放され、そのとき
空気が通ります
が、
これらの特定の音について私たちが得ることができる素晴らしいヒントが1つあります。
今から机を下げるつもりです、
おっと、
申し訳ありませんが、 机の上には物がたくさんある、
私の机はちょっとおかしくなっている、分かった、分かった、
ゆっくり下げよう、おい、高級な机を持ってる、
そうだ、背中に椎間板ヘルニアがあるから、
スタンディングデスクを使わないなら、できるよ
仕事が全然終わらない
さて、もう一つの興味深い
ヒントは、
K の音と G の音は
本質的に同じです。唯一の
違いは、
G の音では
声帯を使っているということです。
私はまた「k」の音を出します、
あなたの舌が口の上部の「
うー」の後ろ上部に触れているのを感じることができます、
それは正しい「k」の音です、そしてあなたがあなた
の声帯の上に手を置いて
ボイスボックスに置いてください
空気が出ているだけで
声帯は振動していないように感じます
が、同じことをして「
G」の音を出すと、
声帯が
振動していると感じるでしょう。
Kの音
とGの音の違いは、やはり
ボイスボックスを使っているということですが、これが
私が皆さんと共有したかったヒントです、
ええと、日本語では、先ほど
話したGの音を言うときに、
1 秒前の KNG での舌の位置をまた簡単に
説明します。
これが
日本語の K G 音の舌の位置ですが、
日本語で早口で話すときは
これです。 音声学の講義のようなものですが、
それでも重要です、はい、
ほとんどの人にとって理解しやすい方法で物事を分解しようとしていますが、
ここでのヒントは、
日本語を早く話している場合、
舌が滑る場合があるということです Gの音を出すときは
実際には口に完全に接触していないので、
日本語の「鏡」、
そして私がそれを言ったら、
私が今しているように非常に意図的に知っていますかがみ、
それは私の舌を止めるのが難しいです
実際に接触すると、
非常にクリアなGの音を聞くことができます
が、私が早口で話すと何が起こるかというと、
多くのネイティブスピーカーが
Gの音を不明瞭にするので、何が
起こるかというと、舌が
この位置に近づくことになります。 この接触
位置、ええと、ここの上ですが、
実際には完全に接触することはなく、
このような乱雑な感じになります、ええと
中間で失礼します、みたいな感じなので、
ここで
また違いが早くなります、言うのが
不自然です 私が
そのような不明瞭な音でゆっくり言うと、これは
人々が言う早口で常に起こります、
そしてあなたは他のGの音でも同様にそれを聞くでしょう、
それでそれは言い訳のために知っておくための良い
ヒントです
G の
音は私です。では、
これらの音に進みましょう。
これらについてカバーできる興味深いことがたくさんあります。
鏡を見たように、短い文で言ってもらえますか。
それで、G は K のように聞こえます。 でもそれは喉の奥にある 喉の奥にあるというほどではない
ただ
声帯を使っているだけだ 分かった、それではまた、
vs go
ok
彼女、彼女、前に話したことがありますが、
時々 G が次のように発音されるのを聞いたことがあります、それは
実際に取り上げるのに良い興味深い点かもしれません実際にすぐに戻りましょう
これについてのビデオが YouTube にアップされています
が、私はそれだと思います ええと、
何回もカバーするのは良いことです 日本人はいいねって言います
が、その後、彼らはそのGの音をええとええと
はい、
これがいわゆるごめんなさいとして知られているように鼻音化します
私はそれがええ、ええ、まさにそうだと信じています、
これはこれは
これです これは、
非常に複雑なルールと
基本的なルールがあり、
G の鼻音化が知られていると聞いた人には、
G 自体が実際には
鼻音ではないため、G を言うと
Got と言うような基本的なルールがあるのです。 音、鼻を塞いでも、
それは同じですよね、
鼻腔への通路が開いていても
開いていなくても変わりません、しかし、
なぜ、なぜ人々は
時々そう言うのか、そうでないのか
なぜ時々鼻音になるのですか、これは
として知られています、
そして、誰かが
そこに漢字を書いたことがありました、ええと、
それは4本の螺旋状の腕です、これは一種の簡単な
説明のようなものです、これはかつて
日本語でより一般的でした、
そして、 いつそれを使用すべきか、使用すべきではないかについては非常に複雑なルールがありますが、
日本語話者にとって実際に考える方法は、
ゆっくりと「えー」と発音するこの現象、
または前に鼻音がない場合でもGの音を鼻音化するこの現象です。
それは N か an か M のようなものです、
そうですね、
この現象はゆっくりと消えていきます、
そして多くの若者は
何もしないので、
G の音を鼻音化しません、
そして私は 日本語学習者には、
G音が鼻濁音化するこの現象に注意するよう勧めます
が、ルールが複雑すぎるため心配しないでください。この
現象は
比較的近い将来、日本語から完全に消える可能性があり
、たくさんの言語が存在します。
ネイティブスピーカーはとにかくそれをしない
ので、
あなたがやらないのは問題ではありません、
ああ、あなたは怠け者です、そして
あなたはそうすべきです、
そのほうがよりネイティブに聞こえるからです、それは真実ではありません、あなたは
「そうし
なくてもとてもネイティブに聞こえるよ」
強調したのは、日本語では
唇は比較的中立的に話されており、
これはかなり重要な点であり、これは
多かれ少なかれ日本語全般に当てはまりますが、
日本語には次の
ような唇を使わなければならない音がいくつかあります。  M の音、P の
音、またはえー、
B の音、これらは唇を
使う両唇音または口唇音ですが、
このような音の場合は、あー
S の音のいずれかで、
あまり心配する必要はありません。
これは重要です。
なぜなら、あなたが英語のネイティブ
スピーカーなら、おそらく
この行の 2 番目の音で「シー」と言っているはずです。そのため、
この音を発する
ときは唇を前に突き出している可能性が高いからです。 あなたが
この音を言うとき、あなたはこれを言います、なぜなら英語では、
私が彼女と言った場合、私が彼女と言った場合、
女性または誰かを
そのように識別する代名詞を知っている、私が彼女を見なさい、
私の唇がどのように突き出ているかを見てください、彼女と言った場合のように、これを言います。
彼女、
これはこれでは起こりません、ああ、
ごめんなさい、ここでこの音が聞こえますあなたの唇は
中立です、だからあなたは知っています、だから
日本語を話すときは一般的にあなたの唇を心配する必要はありません、だから日本語を言うときは注意してください、
そうだね この音は唇を突き出さないでください、
唇を突き出さないと、より自然に聞こえるでしょう、わかりました、クールです、
日本語の
音またはトグルに進みましょう、それでは触れました、
これは私が使いたいえーの例です
グラフィックとそれは、
イギリス紅茶では舌の位置が
日本紅茶とは違うからです、ではイギリス
紅茶ではこれはどういう意味なのでしょうか
すぐにこれを脱いで
英語チームを立ち上げるつもりです
舌の先端がどのように
歯槽堤として知られるところに入っているかに注目してください。その
ため、上の歯の間、またはそのすぐ後ろに小さな小さな突起があり、上の歯のすぐ
後ろにあります。その小さな突起に
舌が触れています。その小さな突起は
歯には触れていません。
さて、これは
舌の先が
上の前歯の裏側に触れている日本茶とは対照的です、ええ、
上の上の
ええ前歯の裏、
それでは
また、これは英国のお茶です、
舌がどこにあるか見てください 配置は、
これも
日本茶です。舌の先端は
上前歯の裏側に触れ
、その後、舌の刃として知られる部分に触れます。
つまり、
舌の噛み部分は舌の先端のすぐ後ろにあります。
歯槽尾根に触れている
ので、
聞こえ方に関してはそれほど大きな違いはありませんが、
違いはわずかです。日本語をできるだけ自然に聞こえるようにしたい場合は、
もう一度自分がそうであることを知ることが重要です
日本語の音声では、舌の先端が上の前歯の裏側に触れているはずです。
それを探してみると、日本語
話者が「あー、T」と言うとき、英語話者よりも日本語話者の舌が実際に見えることができます。
日本語話者は、
日本語には
副詞が圧倒的にあるみたいなことを知っていると言っていますが、
それは面白かったですで終わります。
私が留学していたときに、私の日本茶は日本茶っぽくないと言っていた日本人の友達がいました。
私は「
何言ってるの？」って思ったけど、彼は「
ノー」って感じだった。分からない、
あなたの舌について何かちょっと違うように聞こえるし、
私は
本当のことのようで、彼はそう言った、そうだ、
これを言ってみて 彼が
ゆっくりとそれを言い、テに到達したときのことを覚えています。
英語のネイティブスピーカーとしてのテがどのように聞こえるかについての私の先入観から想像していたよりもずっと彼の舌が見えました、
そして私は驚いたのを覚えています それで私は「
ああ」と思って、少し調べてみたら、そうです、
日本茶は
イギリスチームよりも口の中でより進んでいることが
わかりました。
それはもっと有志的なものですか、
ああ、それも本当に良い質問です、
だから
私たちは今すぐそれに答えることができます、実際、
面白いことに、
数年前に出てきたミームがありました、それはああ、
それは願望についてでした、ああ、それは大丈夫という理論がありました
ええと、日本語には願望があまりない
ので、人々は英語ほど強く息を吐きません。
おそらくそれが、コヴェットが
日本でそれほど普及していない理由です。そこで、
Twitterで話題になったこのビデオがありました
この日本語を話す人に、彼女は、
ええと、これはペンです、はい、ティッシュを持っています、
心配しないでください、カバーしました、それで
とにかく、ええと、
彼女は最初に英語で話します、そして彼女は、
これがペンであることを知っている、
そしてそこにあることを知っていると言っていました
英語のTにはたくさんの願望が含まれているので、そう言うなら、
Pが英語で言えば
KTまたはPに聞こえます、ええと、キル、キル、キル、
キル、またはええと、ごめんなさい、それは
一種の暴力的です、ええと、
カンガルー、カンガルー、ええと、ケールは
単なるです 良い例です kill
um ピーナッツ
ペンです。組織がどのように大きく動くかがわかります
が、日本語の ktnp 音は
英語の音声ほど有気音ではありません。
つまり、これは本当に素晴らしいことです。
英語のネイティブ
スピーカーです。なぜなら、
話しているときに自分がこれをしていることを知らないからです。しかし、
英語の
K は、実際に含まれる願望の量に聞こえます。含まれてい
ない場合は、劇的に減少します。
キットがあれば、完全に消える可能性があります。  「K」の音の前に「S」という
ので、もう一度言うと、組織を殺すのが見えます、
組織が動いているのがわかります、そう、組織を殺してください、それは動きますが、私がスキルスキルスキルスキルスキルスキルと言うと、本当に大声で言ったとしても、ティッシュは動きません、そしてそれは
なぜなら、事前にSがKの発する音を変換しているからで、
日本語のKは、その音を言う
ときに吐く空気の量という点で両者の中間のようなものなので、もう一度
キルとスキルを続けて言うことにします。
タイムキル、
それは動いています、そう、
キルスキル、
キル、
非常に興味深いです、
これを勉強したことがないなら、
もう一度言いますが、
私が言うなら、日本人はその2つの中間のようなものです、ご存知ですか、
えー、
吸引量はそれほど多くありません、組織はそれほど動きません
今、日本語には
願望がある場合がありますが、
それは人々が
何かを本当に強調しているときや、ああ、
ああ、
感情的なマナーのようなものを話しているときとより関係があり、つまり、
私が怒っているかどうかがわかります 英語では、私は神のようになるかもしれません、そして、
私は通常の話し方を変えるかもしれません、そして、より
多くの吸引をするかもしれません、より少ない吸引をするかもしれません、そして同じことが日本語にも当てはまります。  「
ktnp」の「願望」 日本語で聞こえるけど、
一般的に言えば、日本語では英語ほど息を吐いていないので、
Twitterで女性が「
これはペンだ」と言っているのに対し、それは多くの批判を浴びていることがわかります。
人々はこれは
とてもばかばかしいと思っていたので、
日本語のせいで、うーん、この切望が広まるわけがありません。また、
女性が「Pの音を知っていますか？」と強調していたため、
これはこのようなペンであることを知っていると言っていたからです。
ペン、そんなの知ってるけど、
確かに英語で「ペン」という単語を日本語で言うと、
日本版では吐く空気が少なくなるから、
ここで外国のミームをすぐに再現できるかもしれない
けど、自分がそうだったのを忘れてた 日本語を話している
ので、
これはペンです、これはペンです、やり直しさせてください。でも、私が
日本語を話し、自然な
日本語を話すと、これはコルドバのペンのようになるでしょう、これと
もう一度これはペンです、これはペンです、これはペンです、
これはペンです 確かに
日本語には向上心が少ないです ktnp は
大丈夫だと思いますので、いくつかの質問が来ています
これらにすぐに答えてみたいと思います えー、わかります、ごめんなさい、多分
大丈夫かもしれない何かを見た気がしました ローガン、文法を覚えるための学習テクニックをお勧めしていただけますか
と漢字、私はこのことを忘れてしまいます
ええと、毎日練習していても、ええと、
感情が伴う文脈の中で単語や文法事項を思い出すことができれば、より簡単に覚えられると思います、
そしてそれが何を意味するか それは
すぐに画面から外させてください、
ええと、
日本語には
剣の鞘を抜くという言葉があり、
それを日本語で
言うことができるさまざまな方法があるので、誰かが「Gの音について日本語で話せますか？」と言っています、
私はいつもそれを聞いています
N として、ストリームの前半でこのことについて話しました。
これを Cordova にピン留めすることをお勧めします。スーパー
チャットをありがとうございます。とても感謝しています。
えーっと、ストリームの
前半で G の音について話しました。
ストリームが終わったら、もう一度見てください。 完了しました その質問に具体的に答えます わかり
ました、それでは日本語の音があります、
それでは、日本語で剣を表す単語は「
ケン」です それを言う方法は複数ありますが、それを
言うことができますが、それを言う方法は1つで、「
キング」であり
、別の言い方があります 日本語で「剣を
抜く」と言える言い方は、「
剣を抜く」とも言えますが、「鞘を抜く」と言いたい場合は、「鞘を抜く」と
言う漢字熟語があり、
私がその単語を覚えている理由は、  「
進撃
の巨人」のエピソードに「進撃の
巨人」を観ていて、このエピソードの中で知らなかった単語をすべて調べていましたが、
その文脈を知っていたので、一度聞いただけでもその単語を思い出すことができました。
その
エピソードは秋だったか、
張が言ったかのどちらかだと思う
エピソードの一つで、
森の中を女型の巨人を追いかけていて、またバッケンって言ったんだ。
Anki のフラッシュ カードに書いてあっただけなら絶対に覚えているでしょうが、
アニメの文脈を知っていて、
そのエピソードが好きだったので、
基本的にすぐに思い出すことができました。
文法や単語を思い出すのが難しい場合は、お
勧めします
その単語のインスタンスを見つけてみてください、ええ、それは
誰かがもう一度書き返した漢字です、
ええと、
興味深いインスタンスもあります、ええと、
インスタンスもあります、アニメにはなかったので知りませんが、
できれば 好きな単語や文法ポイントを見つけたり、
話しているときに間違えたりすると、さらに良いです。なぜなら、
ネイティブスピーカーの前で間違えて
訂正してもらったら、
恥ずかしい思いをすることになるからです。
その記憶には感情が結びついており、
決して忘れることはありません。
フラッシュカードなどを使用するのではなく、文法要点や語彙に感情や文脈を付加してみてください。文脈を追加したフラッシュカードを使用してください。
それでは、
先ほど話しました。
日本茶の様子について えー、舌の位置は
こんな感じで、また
舌先が見えます ああ、ごめんなさい、これは
イギリス茶です 日本茶はこんな感じで
舌先が前上部に触れています 前上部の裏側
これで興味深いのは、
同じことが日本語の
n の音にも当てはまり、日本語の
T の音と日本語の n の音は
まったく同じ舌の位置を持ち、
舌の位置が次の場合にどのように機能するかよく考えられるかもしれません。 同じ
なら、同じに聞こえるはずではありません。
違いは、日本語では、
おっと、
ごめんなさい、急いでグラフィックを入力しなければなりませんでした。
ここで1秒で理解できたと思います。
唯一の違いは、
日本語ではnが次の部分に聞こえることです
鼻腔は開いているので、たとえ
舌が上の前歯の裏側に触れていても、
空気は喉を通って
鼻から出ていくので、舌の
位置は同じですが、
鼻の音であるため、音が違って聞こえます。
そして、T は鼻音ではない
ので、うまくいけば、
プレゼンテーションまですぐに見つけられることを願っています、ごめんなさい、残念ですが、
時間内に準備できませんでしたが、
これもまた日本語の T の
音です。n が次のことであると想像してください。
ここのこの小さな部分がここの
この部分と接触していないことを除けばまったく同じです、この
小さな通路が開いていて、
それが違います、そして、注意してください、
日本語の
tとnでは、舌の位置が
同じであることに注意してください。
英語の n 音や
英語の T 音よりも、
舌の先端が歯槽尾根に触れている
音よりも um の方が前に進みます。わかりました。それでは、これらの音を続けてもいいでしょう。
実際に、すぐに休憩をとりましょう。
かなり急いでいますが、かなり
強烈な用語を使っています 奇妙な質問ですが、
大きな問題があります。これを見てください。 CC なしで
率直な日本語を作り、
多くの話し言葉にさらされるのは
役に立たないだけでなく、私はそう感じています
どういうわけか私は退行しているように、
おそらく試してみてください、そして
これがあなたにとって良い逸話かもしれません、ええと、
私は10代の間かなり熱心に日本語を勉強しました、そして
13歳くらいのときはとにかくかなり熱心に日本語を勉強しました、
私は日本語が大丈夫だと思っていました、
その後、
私も留学前に大学時代に1年間日本語を勉強していましたが、
それにも関わらず、また
留学の最初の6か月間はかなり集中的に勉強したにもかかわらず、
あまり進歩していないように感じました。
あなたと同じ状況で、私は
とても勉強していると思っていましたが、私は殺しました、
まだ鱗を殺しました、本当に理解できませんでした、
私の周りの日本人全員が何を
言っているのかまだ理解できません、
それで私は自分自身に言いました ご存知のとおり、
これはフェーズのようなものなのかなと思います。
これは通過するのかな、それとも背景が白なのでコントラストがもう少し高くなるよう
に画面の向きを変えようとしています。
グラフィックスを取得してみたいと思っています
画面上にもう少し表示したいのですが、何が
起こったのかというと、勉強を始めて6か月の時に奇妙な瞬間があり、
コルベに住んでいる私のいとこを訪ねました。当時コルベに住んでいたので、
基本的に私たちは その週だけ英語で話したり、
一緒に遊んだりしただけで、その後
東京に戻ったときはまるで自分の心のようでした。
なぜなら
東京に戻るときに少し休憩してリセットする時間があったからです。 もう勉強していないにもかかわらず、人々が言っ​​ていることをすべて理解したように突然感じました。
これはちょっと
長ったらしい言い方ですが、非常に長い
時間がかかることを意味する、ある種の臨界点があると思います
何も理解できていないように感じて、それから突然、
多くのことを理解したように感じます、
これは起こりました、これは私に起こりました、
そう、あなたはある種のスイッチが
ついにオンになり
、ああ、これは私と私に起こりました。」
他の人の逸話を聞いたことがあります
が、似たようなことを経験しているので、
一生懸命勉強しているのにあまり進歩がないと少しイライラするかもしれないと思います
が、私は
それを続けてくださいと言います
ある日目が覚めると、突然、「
ああ、ちょっと待ってください」という感じになるかもしれません、
昨日のことのように実際に理解できました、
何も理解できなかったように感じました、だから続けてください、
良くなることを保証します、それでは
これらの音について話しましょう
さて、先ほど日本語で話したように、
唇はニュートラルで、
おそらく日本語の教室で聞いたことがあると思いますが、
日本語のFの音なので、これを
丸めたり、
唇を噛んだりすることはありません。
英語の F の音なので、「忘れる」と言った場合、「忘れる」「忘れる」の
F 音でどのように唇を噛むかに注目してください。
これもまた、英語では
唇が日本語ほど中立ではないからですが、
私たちはそうしません。 これは日本語で、
先ほど話したように唇がニュートラルなので、日本語ではこの唇全体がニュートラルです。
これはたくさんの音に当てはまります。
唇をニュートラルに保つことに集中することに集中すれば、
あなたの日本語は劇的に向上します、
これが自然さです
ニュートラルな唇は話し言葉の
さまざまな側面に影響を与えるので、日本語の話し言葉は劇的に上達します。Fの
音を言うときに唇を噛まないことはおそらくすでにご存知でしょうが、次のようなヒントがあります。
私はいつも人に話すのが好きで、それは
日本語にはかなりの量の外来語が
あり、英語の単語が外来語
になって日本語の単語になっているということです。
たとえあなたが英語を母国語としているとしても、これらの言葉は ご存知の
ように、たとえあなたが日本語の F 音の
F 音をネイティブの日本語の言葉で正しく言ったとしても、
日本語の F 音を外来語で言うと、頭は少し英語モードに戻ります。
これが私が言いたいことです。
たとえば何か良い言葉はありますかと言うと、えっと、それで
魚があります、
えっと日本語で言うと、ふぐのようなものです、あるいはご存知のように、
それはフグと呼ばれていると思います、そう
呼ばれています、
そうそう、それは日本では時々寿司として提供される
ので、もう一度
注意してください たとえ
正しく言えたとしても、
同じFの音を日本語のLone wordで言うと、
英語の音に戻ってしまい
、英語の音に戻ってしまう可能性があります。 遠藤ではなく
誰が
フロレンドと言っているのですが、これは私にいつも起こっていました、
そして私は英語のネイティブスピーカーの他のネイティブスピーカーにもそれを見てきました、
それで
あなたのF日本語の発音を、えーネイティブの日本語の単語とローンの
両方で一貫させることに集中してください
日本語で言うと、例えばファイナルファンタジーを
日本語で言うと、
あなたはそれを意識していないのに、「知ってるよ」と言ってしまうかもしれません。
英語の音ですが、
外来語の F の音に注意してください。それでは、
Mommy Mommy の音に進みましょう。
基本的にこれらは省略します。
一般的に、これは
英語と英語が並んでいる 1 行の音だからです。 日本語は、
日本語の M の唇の位置と
英語の M の点灯の位置の発音が同一であり、
音に関するその他すべてが
同一であるため、
この特定の音についての良い情報は、
何の情報も必要ないということです。
あなたが英語のネイティブスピーカーなら、これらの音はすでに正しく言えています。
それでは、これらの音に進みましょう。それで、
これらの音について、音の仕組みの観点から少しお話します。
これらの音で何が起こっているので、 これらは
グライドとして知られているもので、
Yの音で何が起こっているかというと、あなたが「
ya」の音を言うと本質的にあなたの口
の中で何が起こっているのかということです。詳しく
分解すると、
あなたは「a」の音を言い始めますが、あなたは「
a」の音を言います。
舌をEの位置から始めて発音する
ので、舌を食べる位置に置くと言い、
そこで準備ができました
が、その後、その位置から移動して、
ああと言うので、食べることから始めて、
その後、ああと言い、そして それが
Glide the ya サウンドを生み出すものなので、
本当にゆっくり言うと、ええ、ええ、
e で始まり、
ah で終わるのが
聞こえるでしょう。 技術的に言えば
食べる必要があるような場合に、人々はよく食べることを省略するので、
これをチャットにすぐに書きますが、
たとえば、「
ノー」と言いたい場合の単語、「私は食べません」 それを日本語でやりたい
なら、このヤダと言えばいいので、
このように綴ります ああ、
ごめんなさい、
ええ、まさにそのとおり、
ヤダ、しかし、他の人が面白いアニメーターのジムTVを書いたように、
よく
日本語では、人々はその
最初の食事を省略し、彼らは ヤダヤダとだけ言います。
その理由は、
Yの音の最初の早口で話すのが少し冗長だからです。
あなたの舌はすでに食べる位置にあります
。だから、もしあなたがそうしようとしているなら、
まさに
ええと、それがその理由です 音はすでに
音の中に含まれているのでよく省略されます、だからそれが起こるのです、
とても興味深いですよね、だから
また人々はそうではなく、あなたは知っているとか、みんな言っているのです、
それでまた知って良かったです、わかりました、今では
みんなのお気に入り
[音楽]
日本の R そうですね、
お願いします、
スパムをやめてください、えー
[音楽]
それで日本語の R の音です
多くの人が
これらの音に問題を抱えている理由の 1 つは、
人々がそれらの音を学ぶとき、学習した
内容を正確に文脈の中で学習するからだと思います
私が今言ったことは、日本語の
R 音は R 音以外のものである場合、それら
は R 音ではありません。これらを R 音として概念化しようとすると、
すでに悪いスタートを切っているので、
r 音について言って申し訳ありませんが、
何が起こっているのでしょうか これらの音では、
バター以上という単語を言ったときに起こることとまったく同じです。
そして、舌が
歯槽尾根に触れている様子に気づきました。
だから、
すぐに英語の T の音に戻ります。
これは
英語の T 音の舌の配置であり、これは
実際には
日本語の R 音の舌の配置でもあります。
日本語の R 音を言うと何が起こるかというと、
舌の先端が本当に素早く
歯槽堤に当たります。 もう一度この小さなスポット、
えー、上の後ろの前歯のすぐ後ろの間に、
本当にその
場所に当たり、本当に素早くその
場所に当たり、それから本当に素早く下にフリックします、それで、
鍵の一つはスピードです、そしてあなたが
言わなければ すぐに発音すると、
少し英語っぽく聞こえますが、もう 1 つ
認識すべき重要な点は、
舌を後ろに丸めるのは望ましくないということです。そうすると、その
音を言うときに遅くなるだけでなく、
それについても言及しておきます。
日本語の「R」の音に問題があるので、
それを邪魔にならないようにしたいのです
が、あなたがこれらの音を言うと、ああ、
このためにアニメを一時停止しました、
レッスンをありがとう、ねえ、喜んで助けます、ああ、パンドラ、B
ペン、ドラゴン、ありがとう
これらの日本の放火を言うときのスーパーチョップにはとても感謝しています。
とても早く言いたいのですが、
チャットの誰かが、
N を R にどうやって発音するのですかと言いました。これは曲がりくねった音のように聞こえます
。これは本当に素晴らしい質問です。
今はとてもとても難しいです
これがあなたの
上の前歯だったら これがあなた
の上の前歯で、これが
あなたの舌だったら 何が起こるかというと、これらの音で何が起こっているかという
と、舌の先端が
上がって舌に当たるということです。 本当に早く、
とても早く起こっているのですが、そうではありません、
この巻き上げの動きではありません、
ここからここまで、そして下に行くだけです、本当に本当に本当に本当に
急速です、今は
混乱しています、なぜなら、音の中で何が起こっているのかというと、
前に見たように、
あなたの先端が 舌はちゃんと歯槽尾根に触れているので、これは
英語のnだけど、また
日本語だと言うと、もう少し
前にあるので、
えー、
私の舌はすでにこの位置にあるので、
日本語と言いたい場合は ベンディの単語
か、
えーっと役に立つのはどちらの単語ですか。
だからこのように綴ります
ベンベンディ 何が起こるかというと、
あなたが「賭けます」と言うとき、私たちはそれをカバーしませんが、あなたが「
賭けます」と言ってから、「
賭けます」と言うと、「
B」になります
エンディ
、だからあなたは言葉の真ん中の歯槽尾根に舌を当てて、
舌を離すのではなく、もう
歯槽尾根と接触しなくなってしまうことを知って、
そこに舌を置いておきます。 あなたは
舌を接触位置から下に動かします、
だからそれは
また曲がるわけではありません、もう一度やります、きっとそうではありません、うーん、曲がっています、
舌が舌に触れたら同じ接触を保ちます
歯槽尾根の接触位置は、
そこから「r」の音に移行するときに、
舌の間にリセットがなく、そこに留まり、
すぐに下にフリックします。これが、
多くの英語ネイティブスピーカーが
この音に問題を抱えている理由です それは、
彼らはこれを知らないからです、そして彼らは
音の途中でリセットしようとします、彼らは
大丈夫ベンBのように言うでしょう、
そしてそれはあなたを遅くします、
しかしそれは曲がりくねっていました、それであなたの
舌を
歯槽尾根のそこに当てておいてください、そして そこから直接「
えー」という音に進みます。
日本語の「R」の音には
タッチとリリースがあります
が、その前に音がある場合は、「R」の音の
タッチ部分が「R」の音になると考えることができます。
あなたはそんなことはしないで、
rの音のリリースをするだけです、大丈夫です、そして
これはあなたに当てはまります、ああ、
曲がりくねった、ああ、申し訳ありませんが、それは私のスクロールですシンディです、大丈夫、
in音の後にrをフリックする必要があるように聞こえます、はい、まさにその
通りです 正解 わかりました、
ひどいですね コーナー、おいデューガン、
今日はどうですか、いいですね、皆さんはどうですか、
このチャットを楽しんでいます、うーん、
今、ああ、そうそう、
聞いたことがあるのですが、
r l と D のようなものです、そうです、
r については 2 つの専用レッスンがあります
うーん、今日私が話してきたことはすべてそうだ
ね 情報が
たくさんあるので、かなり早く理解できたけど、
ここで、
patreon.com で日本語の発音とピッチアクセントのレッスンを知っています。私が自分のことをすべて
説明します
私のpatreonシリーズの日本語の
音声学で、もっと単純で明確に整理された用語で今話しています。興味があるなら、
rの音についての2つの専用のレッスンがあります。非常に体系的で、非常に
体系的で、ゆっくりと「これは大丈夫です」と言います。
舌の位置 これはまさに
起こっていることです、そしてまた、
以前にネイティブ録音で見たのと同じグラフィックスが使用されているので、
興味のある人は今すぐそれらをチェックすることをお勧めします うーん、
うーん、Oと音の両方について話しましょう
ちょっとそれでは、
ここの真ん中の音から始めましょう。
日本語のオブジェクトマーカーです。
この音の技術的に正しい発音は、
先ほど見た日本語の母音と同じです、
つまり、これらの最後の母音はこの音です
知ってるよ、これの発音
とこれの発音は
技術的には全く同じだ
から、日本語の発音の教科書みたいに買うと、
全く同じに発音するべきだと言われるだろうけど、日本語話者はよく発音する
ことに気づくかもしれない
この
音は、おっと、
ほとんどあるような、ほとんどあるような、
その前にwがあるような、または
その前に少しあるような、羊毛のような音です、それで
ここで何が起こっているのでしょうか、そしてこれは
単なるaのようなものです、
私は信じていません しばらくしてこれを調べました
が、以前は
それがこの
単語の正しい発音だったと思いますが、
時間が経つにつれてそれがオーに進化しただけだと思います
が、まだ多くの人が「そうするよ」「そうするのは
良いことだ」と言う人がたくさんいます 教室では
ほぼ確実に、「ああ」は
常に「ああ」と言うべきだと習いますが、
外に出ると、
ネイティブの話し声が聞こえます。ネイティブが
日本語を話しているのが聞こえます。そして、時々
これが聞こえ、
それは「ああ」です。 それは私が学んだことではありません
ここで何が起こっているのかを何度も繰り返します それは
これで
いいのです それは
周りの音に依存するので難しいので、
誰かが誰かが書いたので、それは実際にそれによって
決まります
話し手によって異なります
状況によって異なります それはそれです かなり
複雑ですが、
この音について私が日本人に与えたいヒントは、
あなたはおそらくこの音を学んだかもしれませんが、かなりの
数の
ネイティブスピーカーが「
A」または「W」のような感じで「えー、
小さい」と言うのを聞くことになるということです。 その前に「W」の音です、ありがとうございます、
アイザック、ローガンのパトロンはあまりお勧めできません、信じられない
ほど役に立ちました、
本当に感謝しています、
ええと、だから私は、
いつもこれを、ああ、この音を
日本語で言うのとまったく同じように言うのが最も簡単な方法です
それが一番簡単な方法で、
ネイティブっぽく聞こえるでしょう
でも、私は実際には
もう少し個性のあるサウンドの方が好きなんです そうだと
思います 両方とも言いますが、実際は
時間と時間次第です その音に特に力を入れたいのですが、
それでは、この音は日本語に移りましょう。
これはおそらく日本語で最も複雑な音です。
私の 2 つまたは 3 つのレッスンで 2 つまたは
3 つかかります。 この音については、私のビデオ シリーズで数分間のレッスンを行っています。
非常に複雑なので、この音は
一般的に「ああ、n の音に似ています」と教えられます
が、この音は実際には
7 つまたは 8 つの異なる音のようであり
、私が言いたいのは
この音の発音です
周囲の音に応じて変化する
ので、
ここに例を示します。私が
日本語のテンポを「テンポ」と言ったら、
私が見ていることを確認してください、
私は
そうです、だから、音楽のテンポと同じようにテンポを知っているでしょう、
それから私はテンポと言うでしょう 天保
寺とか本当によくある
例は、人々が正しいと言うのです
が、もしあなたが「えっと、
この音をNとして覚えたかどうか見てみましょう」と言うと、あなた
はNを言うと言い、それがmに変わると言うでしょう。
ガンベートという単語は、
M になる N として発音するべきではありません
。m として発音するだけです。だから、
[音楽] と言うので、
その後に来る音のサラウンドに依存します。また、a の場合、b の場合も同様です。
この音の後に来る場合、この
音は m として設定されます
が、
この音の後に T が来る場合は、
舌を口の始めの端の位置に置いて言っているため、
10 10 を先に引く
か、10 10 10 と言ったのです
この音は
周囲の音に応じて変化します。
私が「N」と言ったら、
それは
口の後ろで発音される N ですが、
これを詳細に分解するのは少し難しいです。
ほとんどの
人が理解できるように簡潔にまとめています。本当に
グラフィックが必要で、実際には 20
分ほどの時間が必要です。それが、私が Patreon シリーズ
でこれについて 2 回の専用レッスンを費やしている理由ですが、
ここで強調したい主な点は次のとおりです。 これは
単なる「n」ではなく、「
ただのn」だと思っていると、
日本語で多くの間違いを犯すことになります。それは状況によりますが、
これはその後に来る音の鼻音バージョンです。 それの後に来る音の鼻音化されたバージョンです、
それで、
この音について考えるのに最適な方法です、ええと、
しかし、時々舌先を上前歯の裏側に当てて発音することもできます、
時々唇で発音することもできます
時には口の奥で発音することもありますし、
実際に口の奥で発音することもありますが、
もう一つは、
人々が「
待ってください、それはnだ
けど、それは楽しいはずではないですか」というような言葉があるということです。
ここで何が起こっているのか、
これは周囲の音に依存するためで、これの
別のバージョンでは、
この音を鼻化母音として発音するため、
私が日本語の母音を言うと、
鼻を塞ぐことができますが、彼らは言わないことがわかります。 奇妙に聞こえるの
は、単独の母音は鼻の
音ではないからです。だから、
鼻をつまんで、えー、日本語のそれぞれの母音を言ってみます、
ああ、
病気ですか、それは同じです、
でも、
何が起こっているかのような言葉で
何が起こったって言ってるの? あなたはこれを
基本的に
鼻腔が開いている e 音として発音する
ので、それは n 以外の何かです、それは
母音です、鼻化母音です、
だからまたあなたが本当に
知りたいのはゼインにも ゼーンと
発音しないのと同じです、
ヴェインヴェインと発音して、
単語の途中で簡単に鼻音にするのですが、舌を口の
どの部分にも触れさせず、
単に「ヴェインヴェイン」と発音します。 鼻化
母音、そしてもしこれが
少し威圧的な場合は、Patreon シリーズの
2 つまたは 3 つのレッスンに分けてこれを詳細に分解します。
実際に私が与えるドリルのようなものがあります。そして、「
これを言ってから始めて、大丈夫です、今
調整します」と言うのです。 あなたの舌の位置はこのようになります、
少し大丈夫です、もう少し調整して
このようにしてください、そして私は
ゆっくりと
この音のさまざまな発音を
もう一度みんなに説明します、えー、私が本当に
強調したいのはこれです 音は
あなたが思っているよりもずっと複雑で、ああ、
それは
Nだ、ただのNだと思い込んでいると、あなたは
私が何年も同じように多くの間違いを犯しているかもしれません。
えー、この時点で、
後でたくさんの質問を受けたいと思っていますが、
えー、わかり
ました、心理を見てみましょう、これは
あなたのピッチアクセントシリーズの中にあると言います、
最後から 2 番目のナカダカ
動詞は常に の にアクセントがあると言いました。
辞書形式ですが、コットンに
アクセントがあります、説明してもらえますか、はい、
それについては後で説明します、えー、
非常に簡単な答えは、
その単語の最後から 2 番目の音が特別な
音だからです、それは母音です、それは 後続の母音
なので、下のステップがもう 1 つ戻ります。
これについてはシリーズで話します。
わかりました。
それでは、発音からピッチアクセントに移行しましょう。それから、
どちらかについてたくさんの質問に答えましょう。えー、JP よろしいですか、えー、これらのことに気をつけてください
コメント
えー、ありがとうございます。それでは、最後に
発音とピッチ オキシムの両方についてたくさんの質問を受けられるので、
シリーズのこの部分、
または講義のこの部分の準備をするために、少しだけ余分な時間がありました。
よく人々が言うのを聞きます、
ピッチアクセントを勉強するのは有益ではありません、ちょっと
難しすぎます、
あるいはあなたなら、たとえ始めなくても、たとえ
ピッチアクセントを勉強したことがなくても、人々はあなたの言っていることが理解できるでしょう。 これは
本当で、
でももしこれが本当なら、なぜ
私がこれを教える必要があるのでしょう。なぜ誰も
ピッチアクセントを勉強するのでしょうか。その理由は、
ピッチアクセントを勉強すれば、あなたの日本語が
かなり自然に聞こえるからです。
私が言いたいのは、
そうなのです。簡単な答えは、できるだけ自然に聞こえることが
重要である場合、
単にできるようになりたい場合、単に
人々に自分のことを理解してもらいたい場合、ピッチアクセントを勉強する必要があるということです。
こう言うと、
かなり外国っぽく聞こえるアクセントがあることは気にしないので
あれば、高低アクセントを勉強することは重要ではないので、
それは本当に
あなたの個人的な目標になります、私は常に
できるだけ自然に聞こえるようにしたいと思っていました、
そして私が学んだとき このピッチアクセントは、
私が思ったことです。
これを勉強して、私の日本語が
もっと良く聞こえるようにしたいと思いました。
これがその良い例です。
多くの人は
ピッチアクセントを勉強したことがないので、
ピッチ事故の間違いがどれほど多いかを理解していません。 彼らは、
あなたが日本語を話しているかどうかを確認する最良の方法です。これが
あなたにできる良いテストです。「
日本」という言葉を言えますか。日本語
と日本人です。
これらの 3 つの非常に基本的な
日本語の単語を正しい高さの
アクセントでもう一度言えますか。日本
日本語。 日本 日本語と
日本人 これは非常に簡単なテストです
私のピッチアクセントが良いかどうかを確認する
ため、あなたはおそらく私が綴った
日本を表す言葉の言い方を知っているでしょう
ああ、ここでごめんなさい、
ベンディとあなたの間で はっきりしました、
ありがとうございます、
とてもうれしいです、スーパーチャットをありがとうございました、
ロージー、それでは申し訳ありません、
昨日このコメントを削除します、これは
私が準備したテストなので、ええとお願いします、
申し訳ありません
これは
ピッチ事故について勉強していない人のためのテストですので、知ら
ない人が日本語をテストできるように、答えを知っている場合は答えを入力しないでください、
はい、お願いします、やめてください
やめて
大丈夫、
だからあなたはこの
単語の
正しい言い方を知っているでしょう、
今はこのように聞こえますが、日本語という単語は
どうでしょうか。これは
綴りです。でも、どう発音しますか。
少し自分の中で考えて
、発音してみてください。 大声で
覚えてください、
これがこの言葉です、これは日本の高さの
アクセントです、
日本語、
それでは日本語の高さのアクセントは何ですか、日本語は今、多くの人がやっているのは、
まあまあ、全体的にアクセントがあるので、
日本語に違いありません アクセントが
同じ場所にあるなら、もしそれが
家全体にあるなら、それは
おそらく
この単語の同じ穴にあるので、おそらくそうです
が、これは間違っています、日本語ではありません、そうではありません、
大丈夫です、そうではありません
あなたがそれを知らなかったなら、
これは
そうです、本当に別々に扱う必要があります、
ええ、それで、正しく理解できたなら、
それは素晴らしいことです、これは
ピッチアクセントを勉強したことがない多くの人がよく
間違えることです そして、ピッチアクセントの勉強を始めるまで、私もこれを
長い間間違えていました。わかりました、
次の単語の答えを入力しないでください。
でも、わかりました。今度は日本人に移ります。
この単語は
日本人向けの単語の綴りですので、もう一度、
ああ、日本のアクセントはこうです、
そして日本語の場合はこう言ったので、
この単語の日本のピッチアクセントパターンは何でしょうか?
それを言うつもりはないので、
すぐに自分で発音してみてください、
それはそうですか、うーん、それらの
違いが区別できない場合は、
ええと、
ピッチアクセントを勉強する良い理由になるかもしれません。
したがって、正しい答えは、それは
違うということです どちらも
2 つの回答のどちらかからなので、
前の 2 つの回答のどちらでもありません。
大丈夫です。だから、下のステップは、えーっと G の the にあるので、
私たちが持っているのは
膝です、申し訳ありませんが、ここから始めるべきだと思います。
高低アクセントを研究すると、それらは
すべて
日本語に似ていると仮定する可能性がかなり高く、
無意識にこの仮定をすると、また「
うーん、
日本語って言ってしまうかもしれない」と言ってしまう可能性があります。
「
でも、これは間違っています、
ええと、それらは完全に異なります。
これに気づいていない場合、
特に
あなたが英語のネイティブスピーカーである場合は、間違ったピッチアクセントパターンでこれらを言っている可能性があります、わかりました、
ローガン、私はあなたが
主張していることを理解しています」  「にほんご」と言うときのピッチが高くなります
が、いずれにせよ、ホンに関する
金音節のわずかな子孫ピッチに気づきました。
説明してください。
これは、「えー、ピッチが徐々に低下する」として知られる現象であり
、
これについてはピッチアクセントシリーズで詳しく説明しました。
簡単な答えは、
あなたが話しているときに、画面に
グラフィックスを表示しない
と
これに気づくのが非常に難しいということです。私はこのプレゼンテーション用にグラフィックスを準備しませんでした。
なぜなら、私は
それを聞くことや明らかにすることを期待していなかったので、しかし、 あなたが
母国語で話すとき、私が
頻繁に英語で話すとき、私は
比較的高いピッチでフレーズを始め、
比較的低いピッチでフレーズを終わらせます。
その理由は、
話し始める前に空気を吸うからです。
そして、あなたが話しているときに、あなたは話しているときにすぐに空気を吐きます、
そしてあなたがたくさん話していると、あなたは空気が
足りなくなるでしょう、それで、
あなたがより多くの空気を使い果たすほど、
あなたの声は低くなります
その理由は、
高いピッチを出すには、
たくさんの空気を素早く押し出すことですが、空気が
なくなると
高いピッチを維持することができなくなり、
徐々に声が下がっていきます。
非常に簡単に
考えると、
低いピッチで話しているときは、
息を吐き出す速度が遅いのと、
高いピッチで話しているときの違いは、
息を吐く速度が速く、
自然に長い文章を言うために何かを言うために大きく深呼吸すると、何が起こるかというと、
そのフレーズの始まりはハイになり
、そのフレーズの終わりはハイになります。
相対的に低いので、同じことが相対的に起こるような平坦な単語であっても、
単語の最初に口の中にもう少し空気が入っているので、低い高い高いですが、
その後何が起こるかというと、
自然に 単語を言っていると
肺の中の空気が少し減るので、
それが
一言のフレーズであろうと、文章であろうと、
一般的に言えば、
時間の経過とともに微妙にピッチが低下します。
これを分割します。これを分割します。
私のピッチアクセントシリーズのグラフィックスとネイティブ録音を約 10 分で詳細に説明します。
もしあなたがそれを再度興味があるなら、それをチェックすることを強くお勧めします。
段階的な低下について詳しく知りたい場合は、 ピッチは
大丈夫です、なぜ Apple の辞書で nihong のピッチが抜けているのですか、その
理由は、あなたが nihong ではなく、Nippon を見ているのかもしれません、
それが理由かもしれません、
大丈夫ですが、確かに大丈夫だと言うのは難しいので、しかし、私たちはピッチがどのようになっているのかを見ました
アクセントが
どれだけ違うのか、
今何が起こっているのか、人々はああ言うたびに私に尋ねますが、
これは、すべての単語のピッチアクセントを調べなければならないことを意味します、
そうすると、ああ、それは
私がやる気を失うことを意味します もう少し
ネイティブっぽく聞こえるようにするだけでも、とても余分な作業ですが、
良いニュースは、
たくさんの小さなルールを学ぶことができ、その
ルールを一度知ってしまえば、
100 個ほどの単語の正しいピッチアクセントをすぐに知ることができるということです。
これから私がやろうとしているのは、
これらのルールをいくつか紹介することですが、ピッチ アクセント シリーズでは、そのうちの
20 個も 30 個も知らないかのように話していることをもう一度心に留めておいてください。
では、そのいくつかを説明します。では、
これらのルールの 1 つは
マイナス 3 ルールと呼ばれるもので、
内容を詳しく説明していきます。
ええと、
わかりやすい方法で内容を説明していきます。
英語のネイティブスピーカーとして、
無意識のうちに
単語の発音に関する小さなルールが頭の中にあり、これ
まで見たことの
ない単語に遭遇すると、その単語には
特定の高低アクセントがあり、
だからこそ、
英語のネイティブスピーカーが
日本の都市「
大阪」を表す単語を見たら、「大阪」とは言わず、「大阪」「
大阪」と言うのです。彼らには、
英語ネイティブスピーカー全員が無意識のうちに正しく演じているというルールがあるからです。
日本語を勉強しているのですが、
彼らは大阪と言うでしょう、大阪とは言わないでしょう、
大阪と言うでしょう、そして、横浜という単語を言うと
横浜と言うでしょう、そして
川崎という単語を見れば
川崎と言うでしょう 無意識のルールとは、
英語のネイティブスピーカーとして無意識にプレイしているルールがあり、
日本語のネイティブスピーカーが
無意識にプレイしているルールもあり、これらのルールの1つは
マイナス3ルールと呼ばれ、
このルールの基本的な考え方です。
日本語の名詞に
下段やアクセントがある場合、
一般的に言えば、それは
その単語の最後から 3 拍目に現れるということです。
では、どういう意味ですか。
これについていくつかの例を見てみましょう。
これは作られたものです
これを日本語
話者に見せて、
その上にこのピッチアクセントグラフがなかったら、
おそらくこのピッチハックとグラフを言うだろうし、うーん、
私はおそらくそうだろうと言うでしょう。  「マドカサキ」と発音します。
これも
ネイティブスピーカーが無意識に行うこのルールです。
名詞にアクセントがある場合、
一般的に
単語の終わりから 3 拍後に発生します。
このことを念頭に置いて調べます。
外来語がたくさんある
ので、これは外来語である日本語の多くの名詞に当てはまります。だから
どう言えばいいでしょうか。
これは日本語のバナナですよね、バナナ、バナナです、
この単語を英語で言うと
アクセントがどのようになるか注目してください
Super Chat Bonsai Harmony をありがとうございます。曲がりくねったような
発音の問題を訓練するための演習はありますか。
説明は理解できましたが、まだ
正しくでき
ません。具体的にはそのための演習はありませんが、
ピッチアクセントと
発音シリーズがあります
ええと、実は
r の音に関してお勧めの練習がいくつかあります その
うちの 1 つがその 1 つです
ええと、
これをすぐに画面から消します
r の音を正しく言えるように訓練するためにできることが 1 つあります
舌を
接触位置にして言う練習ができる
ので、
のように舌を歯槽尾根に触れさせてから始めて、
それから下にフリックして息を吐きます。 それを
たくさん練習してから、「
ベン・ザ」と言ってみましょう。 曲がる、
それは役に立つはずです、それは
私がお勧めする演習の 1 つです、
私がバナナの英語の単語を言ったら、ここに戻ってください、
アクセントはどこですか、バナナ、バナナ、バナナ、
それは単語の真ん中にあります、右のバナナ、
バナナ
ですが、日本語では
オンではありません 単語の真ん中 それは
単語の最後から 3 番目の拍子にあります
バナナ バナナ なぜこれは、
英語のネイティブ話者が「大阪」という単語を見て「
大阪」と言うのと同じように、
規則があるためです。  「日本語を母語とする人は、
無意識のうちに
マイナス 3 ルールを使って話しているので、
日本語話者が英語を話すと、ほとんどの英語外来語は、
元の単語のアクセントがどこにあるかに関係なく、むしろ申し訳ないと言うのが一般的です
。」
日本語の最後から 3 番目のモーラに移動します。
英語ではバナナですが、日本語では英語ではバナナです。これが
ルールです。ほとんどの和製英語外来語でこれを覚えておいてください。
これらの
外来語は日本語になっています。
アクセントがある
最後から 3 番目のモーラに発生します
単語の最後から 3 番目の拍子です これは
非常に重要なルールです
バナナなので、
これを
英語でもう一度たくさんの例を見てみましょう バスルームを表す単語は、
バスルームとアクセントです は
バスバスバスルームにありますが、日本語では
最後から3番目にバスルンです モーラ 単語の最後から3
拍目
これには例外があり、
例外を予測する方法を詳細に分類しますが、
ええと、
探し続けましょう。
アクセントがどこで大丈夫かという点で、英語と日本語でたまたま同じである単語の例 えー、
続けましょう、でもまたえー 最後から 3 拍目 モーラ 単語の最後から
3 拍目 デスク
オーケー
フルーツ の最後から 3
拍目 「大丈夫、
続けましょう」という言葉を英語で言うと、猫
にアクセントを付けてカメラマンカメラマンと言います。
カメラマン右カメラマンですが、
日本語ではまた
最後から 3 番目のモーラです。
英語では、
キーボード キーにアクセントを付けて言いますが、
日本語ではもう一度言います。 それは Ki ボルド 最後
から 3 番目のモーラ 最後から
3 番目のモーラ 単語の最後から 3 番目のモーラ 単語の最後の 3 拍目 ああ、
オレンジ、オレンジじゃ
なくてオレンジ、また同じです 最後から 3 番目のモーラ ヨーグルト それは違いますが、
ヨー グル 最後から 3 番目のモーラ 単語の最後から 3 番目
のモーラ もう 1 つ
ああ、ごめんなさい、それが最後だったので、
英語の外来
語と日本語で話すのが一般的であることをもう一度覚えておいてください。その単語にアクセントがある場合、
そのアクセントは
単語の最後から3拍目に発生するので、誰かがただ尋ねるので、誰かが
ただ尋ねるだけです 尋ねられました やりますと小さく数えてモーラとして数えます
そして、ええと、それらはしますが、
ルールを破ることができます それが意味するのは、
ええと、
日本語には特別な音があり、
そのうちの4つがあり、
レッスンでこれを詳しく説明しますが、ええと
このマイナス 3 ルールには、ほとんどの例外が存在します。この
マイナス 3 ルールは、
最後から 3 番目のモーラが
4 つの特別な音の 1 つである場合に発生します。つまり、日本語の
スーパーマーケットのような、
アクセントが発生するスーパーではありません。
スーパーマーケットでは、単語の最初の拍である最後から 4 番目のモーラで発生します。それは
正しいです。なぜ後ろにずれるのは、
単語の最後から 3 番目のモーラが
長母音であるためです。特別な
音です。4 つあります。 特別な音で、
最後から 3 番目のモーラが特別な
音なら、10 回中 9 回、
ダウンステップはもう 1 つ後ろに戻ります。わかり
ました。もう 1 つの良い例は、ロンドンを表す日本語です。ええと、私たちは
正しいとは言いません。
明日は最後から 3 番目にはない最後から
4 番目のモーラにあります。
これは特別な音なので、もう
1 つ戻ります。他に特別な音が 2 つあります。ええと、ええと、
はい、
それでは覚えておいてください
[音楽]
圧倒的多数の
状況
外来語では、ダウンステップは
単語の最後から 3 番目のモーラにあり、
それが ああであれば、単語にダウン
ステップがあり、単語の最後から 3 番目の
モーラの場合は、最後から 3 番目の拍子が
a になります。 それは特別な音ですか、それなら
もう 1 拍戻します
OK、そして
ピッチ アクセント シリーズですべての特別な音についてもう一度詳しく話します
が、
ピッチ アクセントについて話続けましょう。
それでは
2 種類の動詞のスライドショーを見てみましょう さて、
それでは、
一般的に日本語では、ピッチアクセントに関して 2 種類の動詞があります。
平坦な動詞と、
単語の最後から 2 番目の拍にアクセントが発生する動詞があります。
それでは、 a を見てみましょう。
これの例がたくさんあるので、
日本語で開くには、次のように綴ります。アケドゥ
で大丈夫です。これは
ヘアボングパターンなので、
ダウンステップがありません。それはありません、ああ、できません、
大丈夫、大丈夫、
だから、これはこれです、ああ、
アクセントがありません それは、
これは 2 つのタイプのうちの 1 つです、
もう 1 つのタイプは、これは、
この単語の「閉じる」を表す単語です、
日本語のように、動詞にダウンステップがある場合、その単語の最後から 2 番目の拍でダウンステップが発生します
常にダウンステップは
単語の最後から 2 番目の拍で発生する
ので、マイナス 3
ルールで
これが
ダウンステップを持つ日本語の名詞にどのように適用されるかを見ました。
また、これは特に
外来語にも当てはまりますが、それは 1
種類です。 単語の
別の種類の単語について話しましょう 動詞について話しましょう
動詞には 2 種類あります アクセント
のない動詞と動詞 ごめんなさい、
あのようなアクセントのある動詞と、
このようなアクセントのない動詞があります
が、動詞にアクセントがある場合は
9 回です 10 のうち実際には、
ダウンステップがアクセントであることよりもはるかに頻繁に、
ダウンステップが
単語の最後から
2 番目の拍で発生します 単語の最後の拍まで
OK、
これがフラットであると判断します。
ダウンステップはありません。
これは非常に重要です。なぜなら、
あなたが英語のネイティブスピーカーなら、
あなたがそうである可能性が高いからです。
日本語の動詞はすべてアクセント付きで言いますが、日本語の一部の
動詞だけアクセントがあるので、
大丈夫ですが、
日本語には
この動詞の構造がかなり
似ている動詞があるにもかかわらず、非常に外国っぽく聞こえる「きめろ」と言っても大丈夫です。 構造
というか、
この動詞の構造とかなり似ていますが、発音は
大きく異なります。
アクセントはありますが、kimeru には
アクセントがありません。それでは、動詞には 2 種類あります。1
つはアクセントあり、もう 1 つはアクセントなしです。
10回中9回アクセントがある 単語の最後から2
拍目に出現する 単語の最後から2
拍目に対して目立つ 単語の最後から2拍目
再び保持する 単語の最後から2拍目
単語の
最後から2拍目
to change
これは平坦な動詞です オーケー、アクセントはありません
to stop アクセントはありません
U
so kind to to accept to sorry
うーん、
そうです to beAttended toAttend to
これを翻訳するのは少し難しいですが、これは私が示しているだけです
ああ、この長い動詞をここに挙げる
と、長い
動詞であっても、その長い動詞にアクセントがある場合、
それは
単語の最後から 2 拍目に発生することがわかります。オーケー、
オーケー
、私は辞書について話しています。
形なので、
アクセントのある動詞とアクセントのない動詞が存在します。
私は
これを繰り返して強調しようとしています。もし
動詞にアクセントがある場合、それは
2 番目に 10 回中 9 回発生します。 この言葉の最後の道徳
さて、よく考えている人もいるかもしれませんが、「家に
帰れ」という日本語はどうでしょうか、
そこで何が
起こっているのか、最後から2番目ではなく、
最後から3番目か、
最初のビートで起こっています。 単語の、または
中に入るのと同じように、それは
最後から 2 番目ではなく最後から 3 番目で発生します。
これらは、先ほど
説明したルールの例外です。わかりました。ここで何が起こっているのかというと、最後
から 2 番目のモーラが末尾の母音であるということです。
単語の最後から 2 番目の道徳 最後
から 2 番目の拍が母音の場合、そのダウン
ステップは
1 拍戻るので、「
しかし」ではありませんが、「しかし」ではありません。つまり、
単語の 2 種類の動詞には、ダウンステップのないものと、
ダウンステップのないものがあります。
このグループのダウン ステップでは、10 回中 9 回、
ダウン ステップは
単語の最後から 2
番目の拍で発生しますが、動詞の最後から 2 番目の速度が名詞の場合は、さらに
1 つ後ろにシフトし、
別の拍子のようになります。 この例は、
カンガエルではありませんが、それで、
先ほど誰かが質問しました、えー、質問がありました、
これについて話しました、
コメントセクションで特にこれについての質問がありました、
えー、誰かが
ごめんなさい、今コメントが見つからない
けど、それは完璧だと言いました
私が何であるかの例、私が今話したのは、
単語の最後から 2 番目の拍子が「えー、それはもう 1 つ戻るだけです、
えー、
それは良いことです、それは良い点です、
それは例外中の例外です、
そうそう、それで」 実際に
はもっとごめんなさい
[音楽]
ああ、ごめんなさい、私はそれを間違って読んでいたと思いますとにかく、
私たちは
100種類の例外のうちの1つのように、本当の本当の本当のことを見始めています
、なぜならそれを見ているほとんどの人は
壊れるメリットがないからです 小さな
例外はすべて、ルール全体の
大きなことに集中したほうがいいです。
なぜなら、
これを覚えていれば、
日本のピッチアクセントの
打率が上がるようなものだから、それでも
いくつかの間違いはするでしょう、それでも
ルールには例外があるので、時々スイングしてミスすることもあります
が、これまで知らなかったとしてもこれを覚えていれば、
ピッチ
動作の平均が
一般的に上がるので、
大きな影響を与えるこれらの大きなルールを覚えておきたいと思います
。
はい、正しく解決します、ほとんどの場合、
打率は向上します、
それでは続けましょう、先ほど、
動詞には 2 種類あるという話をしました えー、
アクセントのある動詞と
ない動詞があります
しかし、多くの人はおそらく、
動詞に
アクセントがあるかどうかをどうやって知ることが
できるのかと疑問に思っているでしょう。すべての動詞を
1 つずつ調べなければなりません。
調べなければならない動詞がいくつかありますが、 いくつかのトリックを知るだけで
高低アクセントを覚えることができる動詞がたくさんある
ので、これの本当に良い例として、
目立つ単語を見つけさせてください、
そう、ここにあるのですが、
少し前にこれについて YouTube ビデオを作りました しかし、たまたまそのビデオを見なかった人のために、
日本語のすべての動詞で終わる
すべての動詞には例外なく
ダウンステップがあり、そのダウン
ステップは最後から2番目のモーラで発生するので、
マツを保持する必要があります。
日本語のすべての動詞が役に立つのを待ってください、で
終わる動詞にはアクセントがあり、最後から 2 番目のモーラに出現します、たくさんの動詞があります、
またこのようなたくさんのルールがあります、
これらの素晴らしいルールは
暗記するようなものです ルール 1つのルールを暗記する
と、突然
多くの単語のピッチアクセントがわかるようになるので、
ピッチアクセントは恐ろしいです、なぜなら
あなたは最初は、ああ、なんてこと、
すべての単語のピッチアクセントを覚えなければならないと思うからですが、それは真実ではありません、
それは完全です、誤解です
あなたは重要なルールを暗記すると、
すぐに日本の
打率が再び上がります、あなたは
まだ間違いを犯すでしょう私はまだ
間違いを犯しますが、あなたなら
10か15のルールを覚えています、もしあなたが勝ちたいなら20のルールを覚えています
もっと詳しく知りたい場合は、大
規模な結果を確認するために、ほんの少しの時間ピッチアクセントを勉強するだけで十分です。それで、
今からこれらのルールの別の 1 つを見ていきます。1
つ前のルールです。 私が
言ったのは、動詞に a があるかどうかをどうやって知るかということです 動詞には
2 種類あります
高低アクセントのある動詞 アクセントのある
動詞とアクセントがない動詞
しかし、動詞が a であるかどうかをどうやって知ることができるのでしょうか
動詞がどのファミリーに属しているかをどうやって知ることができますか。
また、
動詞が で終わる場合、
明日は常に 2 番目のクラスになりますが、一般的に
で終わる動詞には別のクラスがあることがわかりました。
これにはいくつかの例外がありますが、動詞
一般的に言えば、
アクセントはありません。それでは、この日本語の単語の例をいくつか見てみましょう。
飛ぶという言葉です。そうではありません。
高いです。スーパー
チャットをありがとうございます。バットマンは本当に感謝しています。
それで終わったら、 それはおそらくアクセントがありません
誰かを呼ぶ日本語の動詞は他に何と呼びますか それはヨブでは
ありません
それはで終わるのでアクセントがないので飛ぶことも呼ぶことも本で終わるので
アクセントはありません
日本語の単語を続けましょう 遊ぶかたむろする
それは
英語のネイティブスピーカーではありません 私自身も含めて
過去の私も含めて 私は
これを本当に本当にひどく間違って発音していました 私は
それがアソブではないと言うでしょう またアクセントがない
それはブックで終わるので、あなたは
それを「」で言わないでください アクセント このまま続けましょう
ええと、例外はありますが、
それらも例外であり、ルールをすでに学習する
までは小さな例外について心配する必要はありません。
だからこのままにしましょう。
ルールの例をもっと見てみましょう。それではケリー
で終わります。 ブー だから、ハコブじゃないよ、ハコブだよ、大丈夫、
私の注目すべき学習でそれはで終わるから、ないよ、
ないよ、えっとアクセントがないし、
並ぶことができないよ、アブじゃないよ、
アブじゃないよ、大丈夫だ
から、また一般的に言うと、
動詞がで終わる場合は、ほとんどの場合、 ブー、そしてあなたは
その動詞の個々の高低アクセントを覚えていないので、
時々間違えると仮定するのは安全です
が、動詞にはaがないと仮定するのは安全です、
今はいくつかのアクセントがあります
これには例外がいくつかあるので、そのうちの 1 つは、
アクセントがあるようにそれを選択することです。もう 1 つの一般的な例外は、大丈夫と叫ぶことです。そして最後の 1 つの共通例外は、幸せになるか、または一種の
喜びで満たされることです。
先ほど見た動詞は
青で終わるものが
ほとんどで、
青で終わる
動詞はそのほとんどであり、このリストに含まれていない動詞もたくさんあります。で終わる動詞は他にもたくさんあるので、動詞が青で終わるかどうかをもう一度覚えておいてください。
アクセントがあるので、
もう一度これらすべてを見てみましょう。
それでは、
アクセントを使わずに
誰かに電話をかけるのは、アクセントがありません、ああ、
申し訳ありませんが、誰かがスーパーチャットゴールドサンダーをしました、
ああ、どうしたのですか、ありがとう、
えー、
スーパーチャットについては本当に感謝しています、えー、わかりました、
クールに続けましょう、
平坦でアクセントはありません、それから 3 つの
3 えー知っておくと良いです 例外として、もう少し
一般的ではないものがいくつかあります。 それは避けたいのですが、
これは
非常にまれなことなので、その例外は省略し、
一般的な 3 つの例外だけを説明します。
これら 3 つの例外を覚えていて、
日本語の動詞のほとんどが boo で終わることを覚えておいてください。 平らです、
すぐに日本語の高低アクセントを改善します
えー、また打率が
上がります えー、パーティーを始めましょう 動画をありがとう、こんにちは、お立ち寄りいただきありがとうございます えー、
ちょっと興味があるので、しばらく行ってきました えー、わかりました、わかりました、しましょう
続けてください
ああ、分かった、分かった、それが
今日のプレゼンテーションで私が本当に取り上げたかった最後の点だった、そして
私たちが目指してきたのは、
このライブストリームがどのくらい
続いているか知っている人はいますか、私は11時に始めたので ああ、そうそう、
この時点でほぼ 2 時間です。
わかりました。
ルールをたくさん見てきました。知っておくべきヒントをたくさん見てきました。
そして、もう一度強調したいことは、
ええと、実際には最後です。 私が
取り上げたかったこと もう一つ
取り上げたいことがありました
多くの人が
私が前に言ったことを教えてください ああ、彼らは
ピッチアクセントを学ぶのは価値がないと言います、
なぜならそれは
とても圧倒されるからです 私と同じように覚えなければならないことがたくさんあります
一言一句ピッチオークションを調べるなんて、それはとてもうーん、
私のモチベーションをすべて奪う
ピッチオックスの勉強はしたくないし、もし
そうしなければならないなら、できれば今のうちに
いくつかの有用なルールを見てください。
マイナス 3 ルールのような、動詞の 2 つの
カテゴリー ルール、そして
また、私たちがその通説を反証したルールも、
いくつかの有用なルールを覚えていれば、すべての単語の高低アクセントを覚える必要はないことを示しました。
いくつか覚えれば大丈夫です。
ルールを覚えて、
動詞の束や
日本語の単語の束のピッチアクセントをすぐに知ることができますが、
ピッチ事故や個々の単語は覚えていません。
ルールは覚えています。その後、ルールの例外を使いたいかどうかは、
実際に依存します。 勉強をどこまで進めたいかについてです。
すべての単語のピッチアクセントを調べなければならないという考えが反証されたことを願っています。
よく起こるのは、ああ、
そうだ、天秤座さん、と言う生徒がよくいるということです 初歩的
なありがとうございます、えー、
最初の Super Chat を祝います。わかりました。
これか何かを押したほうがいい
でしょうか。ごめんなさい、よくわかりません。Super
Chat をありがとうございます。
どうすればこれらのルールをうまく理解できるでしょうか?
それを行うための本当に良い方法の 1 つは、
私の patreon シリーズを見てみましょう。patreon で
私の日本語ピッチ
アクセントシリーズを見てみましょう。なぜなら、
ルールが強化されるようにレッスンを構成しているからです。私たちが今やったことは、
約 2 時間かかりました。 私たちはたくさんの情報を詰め込みました、
これを見てください、これはクールです、これを
見てください、これはクールです、これはクールです、
しかし、あまりにも多くの情報が正しいので、
このすべての情報を処理するには、そう
でない場合は、 この情報を確認するのに少し時間を取ってください。
おそらく
かなりの部分を忘れるでしょう。
そのため、ルールをまだ知らない場合は、
このライブ ストリームが終了したらもう一度見ることをお勧めします。
でも誰かが、ルールを学ぶのにお勧めの本はありますかと言ったので、
私がピッチ
アクセントと発音のシリーズを作った理由は、
ピッチアクセントと発音を学ぶのに本当に良い本がたくさんあるからです。
ここにいくつかあります、すねが作るように、新
魔界の日本語ピッチ
アクセント辞典のようなものです。これは 1
つで、これがもう 1 つです。NHK
ピッチアクセント辞典です
が、これらは本当に分厚い本で、
ルールはすべて日本語で書かれています。
これらは本なので、
あなたの
日本語がすでに非常に高い
レベルに達していて、ネイティブの録音は必要ない
場合には、素晴らしいリソースになります。しかし、日本語を学習している場合は、
おそらくネイティブの録音が必要で、
おそらくピッチを見る必要があるでしょう。 アクセント
グラフィックもあり、おそらく日本語
ではなく英語でルールを説明する必要があるので、それが
私が
ピッチアクセントシリーズでやろうとしていることです
ピッチアクセントについて学んだときに欲しかったリソースを作成しようとしました。
日本語は高低
アクセント言語であり、私は
高低アクセントとは何だろうと考え、すべての研究を始めました、
そして私が行ったすべての研究
が
私にこれらのような本をもたらしました、これらの
日本の本は私にはまだ理解できませんでした。
日本語を勉強し始めて1年か2年くらいで
、残念ながら
この本の中身を見せてはいけないのですが、
この本の中で使われている高度な日本語学の用語が理解できなかったので、読むことができませんでした。
このテーマに関する限られた数の英語の本を探しに行かなけれ
ばならなかったので、非常に良い例の 1 つは、
ティモシー J ヴァンス博士による日本語の音声
です。もう 1 つの非常に良い例は、
ローレンス レブロンだと思いますが、数冊あります。
このテーマに関する本当に良い英語の本ですが、
私の経験では、
これらの本のほとんどは、
すでに言語学を勉強していて
、言語学の用語に精通している人向けであり、
そのため、
これらのリソースの一部が
少し難しくなる可能性があります 初心者向けの
学習では、
本と
CD がよくありますが、この時代では実際にはそうではありません。
誰かが
概念やルールを簡単に説明しているビデオを見るほうが効果的だと思います。 英語を理解するに
は、「これがグラフィックです」と言ってから
ネイティブの録音を再生するので、
本を読んでから
CD に進み、
本を読んで CD に進む必要がなく、
ビデオを 1 つ見るだけです。 それが全体を分解したものな
ので、それが私が
給料と発音シリーズでやろうとしたことです
ワシントン大学のコ
大学での授業とこれらすべての本から学んだすべての情報を取り入れようとしました
私は何年もかけて学習し、
すべての核となる情報をこれらの短いレッスンに凝縮しようとしました。
各レッスンは
簡単で明瞭な英語と、訓練を受けたネイティブスピーカーによるネイティブ日本語の録音による高品質の
ネイティブ英語録音を備えた約 10 分です。
誰かがもう一度答えてください 誰かが言った、これらのルールを学ぶ
ために使用できる本のようなものはありますか
、そして
再びティモシー・J・ヴァンス博士の日本語の音声があります、それは
素晴らしいリソースです、
私はそのリソースからとても多くのことを学びました、
それはそれです 信じられないほど、
そのリソースがなけれ
ば私は今ここにいません えーっと、ピッチアクセントに興味があるなら、
それをチェックすることをお勧めします、ええと、
それは素晴らしいリソースです、
そしておそらく
私のパトロンピッチもチェックすることは有益でしょう アクセントシリーズは、これらの
本の多く
や、アナウンサーなどになりたい日本語話者向けの高レベルの
大学コースの多くで見つけることができるのと同じ情報がたくさんあるからです。
すべてを
非常に簡単で明確で
理解しやすい英語に分解して、
日本語の発音とピッチアクセントを勉強するときに必要なリソースを作成しようとしました。
そのため、
以前の人からよく知っている、「どうすればいいですか？」などの質問がたくさんありました。 あなたは、「
日本語では便利です」と言いましたが、
これは非常
に多くの人がこの問題に苦労しているため、非常に一般的な質問です。
そこで、例を示したグラフィックを使用してシリーズで具体的に質問に答えます。これも
私が抱いていた質問であり、私がこれらすべての
質問に答えたからです。 私が日本語を勉強していたとき、
ネイティブの録音やグラフィックスなどを使ってビデオ形式で
それを公開し、各レッスン
で情報が強化されるような方法で教えました。
ここにその情報の例がたくさんあります。
ここに同じ例がありますが、
ネイティブ録音のものです。
そして、これは私の 2 セントのようなものです。
おそらく 2 つ、2 つ、2 つ、または
3 つ知っておくべき良いことです。
そして、これがまとめです。
レッスン全体を通して情報を何度も強化します。そして、
私のシリーズには、
知識をテストするために使用できる PDF テストのようなものもあります。
ネイティブ録音を含む Anki デッキもあるので、自分
自身をテストして強化することができます。 えー、
あなたの苦手なところは、
それは非常に高品質で肉付けさ
れたリソースです。
日本語の
発音とピッチアクセントについてもう一度学びたい場合は、
私のシリーズのパトレオンをチェックすることを強くお勧めします。
今日ここで話したのと同じことをたくさん取り上げていますが、はるかにゆっくりとした落ち着いたペースでやっているので、
今日はそこに従うのが少し簡単です。
情報ダンプのようなものをやりたかっただけです。
時間があって、日本語
について本当にクールで興味深いことをたくさん学びたい人のための情報がたくさんあります。わかりました。では、
すぐに始めなければなりません。
この時点でおそらく 2 時間ほど経っていると思います
が、その前にどうする
か これについてはどうですか、
いくつかの質問に答えてみませんか。
えーっと、
皆さんが日本語の発音の発音とピッチアクセントに関連したことを考えているかもしれません。オーケー、オーケー、おっと、
おっと、まあまあ 25 ドルなので、ありがとうございます、
この
レッスンをありがとう、行ってよかったです
これらの基本を戻って強化し、
悪い習慣を修正するだけでなく、
より上級の
学習者が自分が正しいことをしている理由を理解できるように、「
なるほど」と思う瞬間を与えてください。
スーパー チャット
とゴールド サンダーをもう一度ありがとう、すごいありがとう
2回目の
寄付、本当にありがとうございます。そして、すごいですね、25ドルです、
すごいですね、本当にありがとうございます、奥様、
独学でconsudoを使っていますが、
ピッチアクセントはまったく正しくなりますか、うーん、
私はそれに慣れていません リソースなので、十分な情報に基づいた
回答をすることができません、えー、
申し訳ありませんが、単語の
正しいピッチアクセントを調べる最良の方法は何ですか。
これは素晴らしい質問です。YouTube
にアクセスして、Dogan 日本語を入力してください。えー、
実は
持っていません。
私のピッチ アクセント シリーズのエピソードです。YouTube
にもあると思います
が、
エピソード 7 です。
シリーズのエピソード全体を取り上げています。
ここに、単語のピッチ アクセントを
調べるために使用できる無料のリソースがたくさんあります。
今チャットにいくつか入力するつもりです えーと、
見てみましょう はい、これが
1 つです、
まあ、もう 1 つありますが、これは
頻繁に使用できる 2 つのリソースです えー、
リソースです えー、
時々間違っている場合があります、それが
理由です 通常は 2 つを使用して、
えー、両方が
同じ情報を持っていることを確認するか、このようなピッチ アクション辞書のようなものを入手できます。
また、iPhone
で入手できる NHK えーピッチ アクセント アプリもあります。
うーん、それは個々のアクセントを調べるのにも素晴らしいリソースだと思いますが、
ルールを学ぶにはあまり役に立た
ないかもしれません
リソース もう 1 つ
使用できるのは、Apple の内蔵辞書です。
これも非常に優れています。わかりました、わかりました、
誰かが別の質問をしました、えー、
これは必ずしも高低アクセントに関係するものではないことはわかっています
が、燃え尽き症候群を防ぐにはどうすればよいですか
日本語 私は
自分自身のモチベーションをよく失っていると感じており、
それはたいてい不利益に終わるのですが、
これに答える前に教えてください、
急いでコーヒーを淹れるつもりです、
気力が失せ始めているので、コーヒーをください
次に、
自分でコーヒーを淹れるつもりです、
実は
コーヒーマシンを温める必要があるので、
最初にそうするつもりです、
どうやって、えー、気分が変わりそうなときは何をしますかについての私の短い答え
自分自身が燃え尽きているということは、燃え尽き症候群を乗り越えようとしないでください、しっかり
休憩を取ってください、しっかり休憩を取ってください
先日、このトピックについて少し読んだのですが、
非常に興味深いと思う情報を見つけました
世界のすべての
主要な宗教が、
毎週何もしない日を設けているのは偶然ではありません。
それは、人間は休憩をきちんと取らなければならない間、常に全力で活動することはできないという事実を
世界のすべての宗教が考慮しているからです。
あなたは
キリスト教やユダヤ教を知っていますか、
あるいは仏教にもいくつかあると思いますが、
イスラム教も知っているでしょう、
世界の主要な宗教にはそれぞれ休憩を取る日があるのです。 あなたがいる
場所では
仕事をしてはいけないのです、それは
また人間は
十分な休憩を取った後、もっと頑張れるからです、これではだめです、
これは言い訳にはなりません、
だからただ横になってください ずっとソファーに横になっていてもいい
けど、
一生懸命勉強してきたのならそれは休む言い訳になるし、だからこそ、
一生懸命勉強してきた人には、
私のようにしっかり休むことをお勧めするんだ」
大丈夫じゃない 週に6日か、たぶん
5日くらい
日本語を一生懸命勉強するつもりだけど、
土日に休んだ自分を嫌いになるつもりはない
それが実際のところだと思う より効果的な
アプローチ
素晴らしい映画
スーパーチャットをありがとうございました
ピッチアクセントの
レッスンと、日本の
日常生活の素晴らしい特異性を指摘する内容に感謝の気持ちを伝えたいです
数十年前に日本で そうですね、
本当にありがとうございます。
スーパー チャットには本当に感謝しています。また
映画が大好きです。
教育コンテンツと
コメディ コンテンツの両方を楽しんでいただけてうれしいです。
映画になる前は小説か漫画だったと思うし、
実話に基づいていると思うけど、
とにかく
映画は好きだけど、
ルクセントに関して言えば、
それは特定の単語のペアだけを対象にするのか、
それともすべてを対象にするのか
同じ発音の単語です
うーん、少し難しいです 英語で何を
言っているのか正確には理解できませんが、理解できるので
あれば、
問題はその
単語にアクセントがあるかどうかをどうやって知るかということだと思います
またはアクセントがありません
ごめんなさい、はい、
コーヒーを作っていないので少し待ってください、はい、
行きます、
外国人が足を打ち砕いたことをお詫びします、
コーヒーを持ってきました、準備完了です ああ、
私はどこにいたの、
何を言ったか思い出せない、ああ、
日本のアフロ、調子はどうだった、
ああ、ハロウィーンパーティーであなたに会えてとてもよかった、
私もこの機会にコーヒーを淹れるべきだ、
いつかルークに会いたい 同様にルークとソフィー
つまり、
たとえばムアクセンターと呼ばれるものがあります。
たとえば、
他の方言で行われているのを見ることができるように、彼らは[音楽]のピッチに違いはありません、
私の説明が下手で申し訳ありません、
ああ、わかりました あなたの言っていることはわかります。
あなたは正気だと思いますが、
日本語にはまったくアクセントのない方言はありませんか。日本語にも
いくつかの種類があるのに、日本語のピッチアクセントを勉強する意味は何ですか？
アクセントがまったくない方言、
または
大阪のピッチアクセントは東京と違うのか、
これは非常によくある
質問です。ピッチアクセントは違うからピッチアクセントを勉強する必要はない、と多くの人が言います。
日本のさまざまな地域では、
ピッチアクセントがあなたがいる
日本の地域によって異なるのは事実です
が、
日本語を話す人が話すとき、10 回の
うち 9 回、10 回のうち 99 回は
1 つのアクセントで話しているのも事実です。 統一されたピッチアクセント
システムにより、大阪人は大阪弁で話し
、文の途中で東京弁に切り替わったりせず、東京
人は東京人のように話し、
オスロ人は東京人のように話します。
彼らは大阪出身です Googleの人は
自分たちの出身地のように話します それはどこにでもあるわけでは
ありません、
英語でも同じです
私はシアトル出身なので、シアトル出身の人のように話します
私はイギリス出身ではないので、文の途中で突然このような話をやめないでください。
だから、地域によってピッチアクセントが異なるため、
日本語のピッチアクセントを勉強する必要はありません、という言い訳をするなら
教室で標準語を勉強することになるので、たくさんの単語を間違えるでしょう。
でも、
日本語のピッチアクセントを勉強していなければ、間違いを
犯すことになるでしょう。 たくさんの単語が
間違っていて、
間違ったピッチアクセントでそれらを言うと、それは
標準的な日本語としては間違っています
UK ドーガンは本物ではありません、彼はあなたを傷つけることはできません、
ええと、
あなたは正しいピッチアクセントでそれらを言っているかもしれません
大阪、大阪、大阪弁は知っています
が、もう一度言いますが、あなたは
大阪出身ではないので、
自然な方法で話しているようには聞こえません。
確かに、日本語のピッチアクセントは
地域によって異なります。 でも、
あなたはその地域の出身ではないので、
ピッチアクセントを勉強せず、自然に聞こえることを気にするなら、
またしなくても大丈夫です。
ピッチアクセントの勉強は、実際には、
私のような人や、
発音を知りたい人にのみ必要です。
できるだけ自然に でもそれは誤謬です それは
真実ではありません うーん、
地域によって高低アクセントが違うから 高低アクセントを
気にするなら家父長制を勉強する必要はありません
あなたは日本の標準語を
ほぼ確実に学習しているので、半分であれば あなたの
日本語は標準語のように聞こえません、
それはあなたの
日本語が断片的に聞こえるので、不自然になるでしょう、それが
意味をなしているといいのですが、わかりました、
GとGとZはzです、
私のアプリがGを適切に受け入れなかったので怒っていました
のGと
発音クイズ、
それを受け入れないのは正しかったですか、わかりました、ああ、これは素晴らしい質問です、ええと、
答えは両方とも同じように発音されます、
そしてええと、私は実際にレッスンを受けています、
これらすべてについてのレッスンがあります、
ねえ、チェックしてください シリーズ それらは
同じように発音されます
それらは
同じように発音されますが、スペルが異なるにもかかわらず同じである理由は、以前は同じように
発音されなかったためであり、
時間が経つにつれて
少しずつ混ざり始め、
その後日本語で重複するようになりました。
文書などのようなもので、
当時人々はこの
2 つを混同していましたが、その後さらに混同され、
今では同じように発音されています
が、英語でも同じ
ように聞こえる複数の音が存在します。
an F
F を使用して音を作ることも、pH を使用して
an を
音を出すこともできます。同じ音を作るには 2 つの異なる方法があります
が、単語によって正しいスペルは 1 つだけです。
あなたが
話しているので、あなたの質問はええと、
GとGとzは同じだと思いますか、
それらは
発音の仕方で同じです、でも
それはあなたの辞書です、えー、
発音クイズなら正解でした その場合、あなたの
発音は正しかったが、
スペルが間違っていたので、あなたは
私たちを作りませんでした、
あなたは発音を間違えていませんでしたが、
それが意味をなすなら、スペルを間違えました、そして私は
その特定のレッスンで約4〜5分を費やして、
これら 2 つの音の歴史と、それらが
どのようにして結合したのか、そして、最近、
これらの音が日本語で
発生する例はいくつかしかありません、わかりました、わかりました、他に
何でも見てみましょう、
ごめんなさい、
今日はドーガンのグッズを着るべきでした、そうすべきではありませんか たぶん、
マーチできるかもしれないので見てみましょう、うーん、マーチできるかも
しれません、それは
大丈夫です、
うーん、私はうんざりするためにここにいます、どこですか、
私の男の子は
すべて同じように発音されますか、それとも
わずかな違いがありますか、これは本当に良いです
質問と答えは、それは
単語によって異なります。つまり、今
挙げた 3 つの音は、
基本的に常にまったく
同じように発音されますが、
それが意味しない場合は、
常に o と発音されるということです。 それは
違います。つまり、私が言いたいのは、
ご存知のような単語がある場合、
その単語の最初の部分は
トルではなく、
[音楽]が
Oの右の延長として発音されるため、
再び高くなりません。
えー、
ごめんなさいという単語を考えてみましょう。
これの良い例を探してみます。
最良の例は、
ええと、誰かを追いかけるということでしょう。
これは日本語では「ああ、
追いかける」と綴られますが、そうではありません。
発音される
か発音されるので、名詞の単語の種類によって異なりますが、
一般的に、
意志はただ1つの長いものとして言われますが、
単語の種類によっては、
動詞の場合のように再び動詞になる場合は、そのようにはなりませ
ん be o だから、それは単語の種類によって異なります。
また、そうです、人々は
今これに例を入力しています。
これは私がシリーズで話しているもう一つのことです。
おそらく
教室でこれを学んだでしょう、e は
常に e であり、そして それはいつもそうなのですが、そうではありません、
これではない例があり、これである例がここにあるので、
シリーズでこれをもう一度詳しく説明します、ええと、待ってください、
本当に大丈夫だと思っていました、
ええ、また同じような感じで 東京トル京、それは
背が高いけど、フォローするのは無理です、それが
すべてではありません、ああ、
自然に聞こえたい場合は区別する必要があります、それが
ネイティブのやり方だからです、彼らは
区別します、わかりました、ええと、ええと特定のアクセント属性があるかどうか知っていますか
ええと、
彼らがいつも言っているのと同じように、彼らが使用する独特の単語があることは知っています、
ええと、でも、
その種のコーラの高さのアクセントについてはわかりません。
申し訳ありませんが、
説明していただけますか どう発音する
か、これは素晴らしい質問です。
これらの音の 2 つは異なって発音されます。
単語の終わりにある 1 つは、ディープスロートのように発音され
、いわば
舌が口の一番奥に触れるように発音されます。
でも、真ん中の N は
口の前で表現されている
ので、また
[音楽] です。
これが
あの音の中で舌が動く様子です。[
音楽]
わかりました、それであなたの質問が答えられるといいですね、
はい、誰かが入力しています out right now
like
eh、a は
常に e と発音されます、いいえ、そうではありません、in を
見ると、
a が付いているほとんどの単語はそう
なりますが、
特定のケースなどの例があり、
コメディービデオを作成しました これについては、実際には、
a と発音されない場合、
e と発音されないが、a と発音される場合、
おそらくこれの良い例は、日本語の「えー、いいですね」のような
単語のようなものです。
たとえば、
ええとごめんなさい、
[音楽]  ]
はい、それは 5 月です、私ではありません、
また私です、私ではありません、メイ 5 月なので
区別する必要がある特定の名詞があり、
それは単語のようなヒラメにも当てはまります。
私は
特定の種類の魚もいると思います、
ええと、それは私です
うーん、特定の動詞にも当てはまります。つまり、
日本語で「受け入れる」と言った場合、
ここは
右から始まります。だから、そうではありません、そうではありません、大丈夫です。
したがって、
状況に応じて e と e を区別する必要があります。
できるだけ自然に聞こえたいなら、
a が常に e で、
o が常に o であるというのは誤解です、それは
真実ではありません、わかりました、わかりました、
ピッチアクションを早い段階で勉強するという
ことは、より少ない発音の学習を忘れる必要があるということです、
そう、
おそらくその方法についての質問があったと思います 早めに
お給料と勉強を始めたほうがいいです
うーん、私がお勧めしたいのは、このトピックに関する私の見解は
時間の経過とともに進化してきているということです
私の現在の見解は、無料でチェックできる YouTube にいくつかのレッスンがあるということです
私もそう思います 日本語を勉強し始めたばかりでも、
最初の 4 ～ 5 レッスンはわかりません。
特に日本語を勉強したことがない場合でも、それらのレッスンを見ておいてください。そうすれば間違いを防ぐことができます。
長い間たくさんのアニメを見る前に、
そのレッスンを見て、それから
おそらく 6 レッスンほどでかなり
良い勉強をした後、
ピッチアクセントと発音を早く勉強したいのでパトレオンにサインアップしてください。
それは可能です。なぜなら、
悪い習慣を直すよりも、良い習慣を身につける方がはるかに簡単だからです。
つまり、
早い段階でピッチアクセントを勉強すれば、
悪い習慣が大量に身につくことはなくなるということです。
私が日本語を話すのは、あまり早くから勉強しなかったからです。その
良い例が、
私の先生がいくつかの教科書で書いた「r」の音です。
彼らは本当に本当に、
うーん、
また非常に誤解を招くような方法で音を教えました。それは日本語の「R」のようなものです。
音というか、このフラップのようなものです、
ええ、このフラップのようなものです、
あなたがこのようにするつもりのようです、ええ、
心配しないでください、私は彼らを受け入れていたようでした、
それが当然のことだと思っていて、
それを修正するのに今まで苦労していました なぜなら、
私の心が決めたから、それを信じたからです。そして、
一度あなたが
脳内でそれらの神経接続を発達させてしまったら、
それを断ち切るのは本当に難しいのですが、
悪い習慣を断ち切るのは、実際にそうするよりも難しいのです。
良いものを確立するので、
すでに
6か月日本語を勉強しているなら、ピッチアクセントと発音を早めに勉強することをお勧め
します。ピッチアクセントの発音が気になるなら、今すぐもう一度始めてください。
わかりました、
日本語との違いは何ですか？ または、日本語の D と
英語の D がどのように
聞こえるかについては、大丈夫です。
これを本当に本当に早く分解するつもりです、
試してみてください、うまくいけば、これができます。
それで、日本語の
R の音は歯槽
打音であり、発音されます。
上の前歯の裏側にある歯槽堤
日本人のD音は
歯槽停止で、
舌先が
上の前歯の裏側と歯槽
堤に触れているため、すでに舌の配置が
日本人とは異なります。  「R」ですが、
日本語の「T」と「D」の調音も異なります、これはストップです、
タップではありません、ストップなので
発音が遅くなり、
英語のDは
日本語と同じ場所で調音されますが、
英語のDは、次の場合はより
遅く調音されます。
標準英語の D について話している
ので、知っていると言うなら、ああ、
申し訳ありませんが、試してみます。えー、
このスーパー チャットにすぐにアクセスします。
スーパー チャットについては、ウェーバーさん、ありがとうございます。
標準英語の D も歯茎です。
日本語の「R」の音と同じように、舌の先端が歯槽尾根に触れていますが、日本語の「R」の
音は歯槽打音で、
英語の「えっとD」と「T」の音は歯槽
停止です。
それで、今の日本人より遅いです。
場合によっては、「またバターといいですね」のように肺胞タップとして表現される場合もあり、そのような
場合は
日本語の「
um R」と同じように発音されるので、それがあなたの質問の答えになることを願っています。
教育と
ジョークをありがとう。 パトレオンには、ストリームの前半のような英語と日本語の音の比較が含まれています。
代替として使用したいと
思っています。ええ、見てみましょう。ほとんどの
場合、私は英語と日本語の両方の録音を提供していると思います
。これはピッチアクセントの
ために私が行っていることです。
英語を母国語としている人にとって、
外国語
と外国語の違いを聞き分けるのは非常に難しいのと同じように、私がやることの 1 つは、「
オーケー、この 2 つの異なる
ヒッチハイクとパターンに乗ってみましょう。ただし、それらを
英語の単語で言ってみましょう
」ということです。 はい、そして、発音サブ
シリーズでは違いがよくカバーされています、わかりました、はい、えー、
これについては発音で詳しく説明します、
または、
シリーズの一部である発音サブシリーズではい、わかりました、
ええと、申し訳ありませんが、ええと 私の
ビジネスパートナーのJPは、私がこれらのことを検討しているときに
いくつかのコメントを手伝ってくれました、
彼は私がここに行く間、パトレオンなどをチェックしているようなものです、わかりました、
パトレオンが非常に優れていることを証明できます、ありがとうございました
とてもステラーなジャン
です、来
学期大阪に6か月間留学するのですが、
その間に日本語を上達させるためのヒントはありますか、
現在N2レベルです、
具体的に日本語のどの側面を
上達させたいかによって決まります。
私の日本語の具体的に何を
上達させたいですか、それは私の漢字ですか、それは私の
スピーキングですか、それは私の書き方ですか、それは私の
読み書きですか、それは何ですか、
そしてあなたはこれから留学するのですから、
練習できると思います 読み書きは世界中のどこでもできます
が、日本に滞在する場合は、できるだけ
多くの会話をするように努めるのが最善です。
なぜなら、日本を離れると、
もちろんネイティブスピーカーと話すのは難しくなります。
そのため、それが答えになることを願っています あなたの質問はわかりました。
高レベルでのあなたの意見では、Patreon シリーズのサブビングを検討しています。
ピッチアクション
ルールが恣意的に適用されているのと、
システムが
存在するほど定期的に適用されているのとの比率はどのくらいですか。
うーん、
非常に多くの異なる要素があるため、言うのは難しいです
ルールを導入するときはいつも、
その特定のルールがどれほど重要であるかを話そうとするので、
早い段階で「
4、4、4、Mora、2、konzi、u、名詞
ルール」などについて話します。そして、これを今すぐ覚えておいてください、
これは非常に重要である
ため、と言いました。 それはそうですが、
シリーズの後半の非常に高度な高度な
ピッチアクセントサブシリーズのようなものです、
ええと高度なピッチアクセントサブシリーズ
私たちが数字のようなものについて話すとき、
数字にはたくさんの例外があります、それで
私はこれがルールだと言いますが、一番最初の
数字についてのレッスンの前に私が言いたいのは、日本語には
数字に関するたくさんのルールがあると言っています
が、例外もたくさんあります。
非常にレベルの高い人がたくさんいるので、この情報を皆さんに紹介します。
これを知りたい人はいます
が、
ネイティブスピーカーが
これらの特定のルールに従っていない場合が半分であることを知ることも同じくらい重要です。
したがって、私は常に基本的に、ここにある
ルールがここにあり、
ここが本当に重要なものであり、ここが
かなり重要であると言うようにしています。 それらはそれほど
重要ではないものです。その後、
どのルールを覚えておきたいかを正確に決定し、
特定の目標に基づいて試して適用することができます。それが
私がそうしようとしている方法であり、大丈夫です私は
よく誰がヴェラールと発音されるかをよく聞きます
摩擦音 口唇摩擦音、または
類似のもの これはどのような文脈で
起こりますか 口唇摩擦音 うーん、触覚摩擦音の両唇摩擦音のはずです 申し訳
ありませんが、
今は答えることができません うーん、
それはちょっと、私が
意図的に決めたことです このシリーズから外させていただくのは、
それはほとんどの人にとって現実的ではないか、
私の研究で見つけられなかったことだと判断したためです。それで申し訳ありませんが、わかりました、
大丈夫、
愛しています、ダガン、あなたはあなたが
私にやる気を与え続けてくれます パルクールを勉強してください クリス、
クールです ちなみに、
私はパルクールをやったことはありませんが、
格闘技のトリックをすることはよくやってました 昔は
本当に本当に夢中でした、
正しいアクセントで日本語を話すことは本当に重要ですか、
それとも日本人は
それほど気にしませんか お分かりかと思いますが、
これに対する答えは、
人による、
話している相手による、というのが
私が言いたいことですが、
ほとんどの人は
あなたが持っているかどうかなんて気にしていないということです。 完璧な
アクセントでも、かなり良いアクセントでも、そうでなくても、
ほとんどの人は
気にしないと言うでしょうし、十中八九、
彼らはあなたを特別扱いしませんが、
あなたがアクセントを持っている場合、多くの場合があります そのほうがずっと
自然に聞こえるよ ネイティブの
人は、すぐに
あなたと話せると思って、
うーん、
彼らの言うことは何でも理解できるだろうけど、
あなたが日本語をもっと流暢に話せるとしても、あなたも彼らの言うことは何でも理解できると思うだろう
あなたが
好きになる必要はないという意味での
私 英語と日本語の両方を話しているとき、私はいつも口ごもるのですが、ええと、いつも
自分に言い聞かせているように、ええと、いつも
次に言うべきことを探しているようなものです
脳内オナラのようなことをするのは、私がそれほど
雄弁に話せないからですよね、
それで、それはあなたも
私が抱えている問題のようなものを知っているようなものです、
だから日本語を
話すときにそのようにどもらない人はたくさんいます
ええと、でも彼らはかなりひどいえーアクセントを持っている
ので、たとえば、彼らは日本語の単語をそうではなく、日本語を言うように、かなり基本的な
日本語の単語のように言います、
人々が言うように、
私が吃音していないかのように言うでしょう 私が
そう言ったときはまったくそうではありませんでしたが、もし
ネイティブスピーカーがあなたの言うことを聞いて、私がその文でピッチ事故でかなりひどい間違いを3回犯したと言うのを聞いたら、大丈夫です。だから、あなたがそうすると言っているのをネイティブスピーカーが聞いたとしても、
彼らはおそらく
同じように親切に答えるでしょう。 たとえあなたのアクセントが
それほど良くなくても、彼らはおそらく「
ああ、この人は馬鹿のようだ」とは思わ
ないだろう、私は彼らと一緒に時間を無駄にしたくない、
誰もあなたをより
劣った
人のように扱うでしょう。 なまりはありますが、
あなたの日本語が自然であればあるほど、人々はあなたがより多くの日本語を理解できると思い込むでしょう、そして
それは同じようなものであることを知っています。
私が英語のネイティブスピーカーであるように、自分の母国語でも同様の事例について考えることができるでしょう。
だから、誰かが
完璧な英語を話していて、
まったくなまりがないのを聞いたら、
他のネイティブスピーカーと話すのと同じように話せると思います。なぜなら、
彼らはおそらくネイティブ
スピーカーだからです。
非常に雄弁な日本人ですが、
私が彼らと話した最初の数分間は、
彼らは、えー、
あるいは最初の 30 秒くらいはご存知かと思いますが、彼らが
非常に非常に優れた意見を持っているかどうか、彼らが何をしているのかはわかりません。 訛りが濃いと、
無意識のうちに、
彼らは私の言っていることがすべて理解できないかもしれないと思うかもしれません。私は
彼らに
同じように優しく接するつもりです。
同じ敬意と尊厳をもって彼らに接するつもりです。私は
誰に対しても接するべきですが、私は選択するかもしれません。
彼らと話すとき、違う言葉を使う それは、
人々が無意識にやっていることのようなものだと思う それは、
スポーツやその他のことに対して同じことができるとわかっているようなものです。
仮説のようなもので、まあまあ、
これはこの人のレベルです、
そして私は彼らがこの特定のレベルでこの特定のことをしているのを見てきたので、
おそらくこの
証拠に基づいて、彼らはおそらく
このレベルでこれらの他のことを行うでしょう、
それでもう一度
ここで私が本当に強調したいのは、人々は
あなたをこれ以上敬意を払わずに扱うことはない、あなたが訛りが
濃いからといって尊厳を下げることはしない、ということです。
あなたの
日本語がより自然に聞こえるほど日本語が上手になります。だから
この時点で繰り返していると思います
が、
ええと、それが真実だと思います、
ええと、あなたは物議を醸すことを知っているかもしれません
、そして私はそれを本当に本当に本当に強調したいと思います
外国のなまりを気にしないなら、
ピッチアクセントや発音を勉強することを心配しないでください。おそらく私よりも日本での生活を
楽しんでいる人をたくさん知っていますが、
彼らはひどいピッチアクセントで話したり
、 発音は悪い
けど、彼らはそんなこと気にしないし、
話している相手もそんなこと気にしないし、あなたも
知っての通り彼らは自分の人生を歩んでいて、彼らは
違う目標を持っていて、私も違う目標を持っている
ので、わかっていても大丈夫です。
あなたの目標は何ですか、どのように聞こえたいですか、
人々にどのようにしてほしいですか、
人々にどのように認識してほしいですか、他人に
あなたをどのように認識してもらいたいですか、すべては
個人の問題であることはわかっています、正解はありません
。 いつもただ
情報を提供して、できるだけネイティブに聞こえるようにしたいなら、
これを勉強したほうがいいでしょう、ああ、わかりました、続け
ましょう、行かなければなりません、
ああ、行かなければなりません、ここで良い質問です、カイザー・フランツ、ええと、
文法をたくさん知っておく必要があります patreon でレッスンをフォローしてください
えーっと、私は実際の日本語を勉強できていない 2B の漢字マスターです えー、
言いたいのですが、
文法をあまり知る必要はありません。それは、
私が一般的に単語を話す日本語を教えているからです
レベルでは、
文レベルで、私はこう言います、
ピッチアクセントと発音については、こう考えるべきです、
文章などで話しているとき、
でも、あなたは
高低アクセントを単語レベルで勉強することで最大限のメリットが得られる
ので、あなたが
私が言っている単語を知らなくても、単語
の意味を知っている英語を画面上に書きます、
漢字と中国語を合わせて説明します 漢字が分からなくても
発音できるようにひらがなを載せておきます。
そして英語の意味ももう一度教えてもらいます
ので、単語を知らなくても大丈夫です。 この
シリーズを活用するための単語です。
えっと、少しだけ日本語の知識があるなら、
それは良いことです。なぜなら、
私がシリーズで教えている単語の多くを知っているからです。
でも、そうでなくても大丈夫です。
私が教えている単語はわかりません。
途中で学べるからです。それが
あなたの質問の答えになるといいのですが、わかりました、
私にとっては、最初にそれを追いかけているだけです、
ええ、ええ、
基本的な活用ができれば
大丈夫です、とても直感的です、そして
ただ ご存知のように、動詞の
えーの辞書形式をどの
ように知っているかのように、アクセントは次のようになります
が、過去の活用ではこうなり、
その後、
ナガダの活用を知っているように、それについて話します
このようになります、などなど、
えーっと、ピッチアクセントシリーズは非常に
徹底的です、
えー、そしてまたそれは
3つのレベルにまたがるようなものです 自然に
聞こえたい人は多かれ少なかれ誰でも間違いなく
少なくとも基本シリーズを通過する必要があると思います
発音シリーズもそうですが、
高レベルのピッチアクセントのものがたくさんあります。
実際に私がこれらのレッスンを特別に作成したのは、
私がすべてを知りたいと思っているような非常に少数の人々がいたからです。
これについていくつか教訓を作ってみてください、
それでは、
当時は私が知らなかったものを見てみましょう、大丈夫、
みんな、まあ、そうだ、始めなければなりません、ワークアウトする
必要があります、
ここ数日ワークアウトしていませんでした、そして私は
すぐに子供たちを迎えに行かなければならないので、行かなければなりませんが、
これを行うのはとても楽しかったです、ああアンディ、タイミングが悪かったので、
今すぐに帰りたいと思っています、友人のアンディ・タキニ アンディは
日本語を教えています、
うーん、ピッチアクトなどはあまり多くありません。
私はそう思いますが、彼は素晴らしい日本語の
先生で、本当に日本語が上手です。皆さんも
彼のチャンネルをチェックすることをお勧めします。
始めなければなりませんが、立ち寄ってくれた皆さんに感謝します。
楽しい時間を過ごしました。これが役に立ったと思ったら、
私に知らせてください。 以下にコメントがあります。
将来的にはこのような別のことを行う可能性があります。
より即興的なものです
が、いくつかのグラフィックスやその
ようなことは問題ありません。
この時点では冗長なので、先に進みます
立ち寄っていただきありがとうございます。
興味があれば、patreon で
日本語のピッチアクセントシリーズのピッチ
アクセントと発音シリーズをチェックしてください。
すぐにまた会いましょう、分かったし、
後で話しましょう、
バイバイ